Okay.
Eh,
will Harris your live man, this is great.
You're on the other side of the camera.
Now let me give you an introduction
for people who don't know.
Will is the man behind the
anatomy of the fighter,
if you ever seen any of those videos,
like particularly the most famous one
was when Conor McGregor threw that Dolly
at the bus with Khabib.
NEUROMAG Madoff was on it and it
became a huge part of the promotion,
which I thought was weird that
it was this shameful act, right?
That he did that.
I mean really awful caught a bunch of
innocent people that were on the bus but
they use it over and over and
over again. That was your footage.
A lot of people didn't
even know it, including me.
No one did. Um, you know, I was telling
a friend of the day, what's funny,
no one has ever heard this.
But when it happened, uh,
I show it could be at the
back of the bus cause he was,
had a smile on his face and I showed
him and everybody else on the bus that I
actually caught condor doing it. Cause
they didn't really know it was Connor.
So I remember it could
be looked at the footage.
I was holding the camera and he was like,
brother, you can get paid from this.
It's like, Bro, this is worth $100,000.
He looked at his manager, Ali,
a shout out to Ali and he was like,
get this, get him, give him some money.
He deserves this. And then I gave it
to the UFC to use for embedded and um,
I thought it,
that was just sit and they promoted
the fight with it and I was like, damn,
I should've just leaned my head to the
right and got hit by the Dolly so I could
not have to be doing a, you
know, a go fund me's and Shit.
Well, what you should have
done is asked for money for it.
That video footage was,
it turned out it was very valuable
because it set up the fight,
which also set up the post-fight
brawl. I mean there was,
there was so much that was involved in
him throwing that Dolly and you caught
that video. They played that
shit over and over and over.
I was actually kind of shocked that they
did that because at the time we were
like, whoa, Connor might go to jail. That
was, that was like legitimate assault.
They use it the next day.
I'm like, I was like, damn,
like WME is when I saw it on like, um,
when I saw it on Fox News and CNN,
I was just like, that's my footage.
You know. Cause you know,
when you build in a,
like a channel or a series like that,
you think, oh, this is my moment. Every,
everybody has a moment.
And unfortunately the UFC promoted it and
shout out to them because they've been
nothing but good to me.
I can't say anything. Uh,
I still wish I would've got shot
in front of you should've got it.
Some friends put, pull this mic up,
but just pull it, just get it up there.
This from your face. There you go.
Right there. Right there. Yeah. No,
you do a fantastic job. I mean,
you really do. And I, like I said,
until that video footage came out,
I didn't know that you weren't even
a part of the UFC promotion team.
I didn't know.
I thought maybe WME had hired you and
this was another thing that they're
working on. I did not know
that you were independent.
Well, what was crazy is that I
started at almost two years ago, um,
I was just sitting at home in Florida.
I was living in south Florida and I was,
I was hanging out with the guys
at the black zillions at Jocko.
I had stumbled over there one day at
the gym and I seen it when I was grocery
shopping and I just stopped in and I
was doing stuff for Shannon Briggs.
Let's go champ, let's go
chill. I was just going yet,
I was going to the a heavyweight factory.
You would, hey, you do all those.
I said, no, I wasn't
doing this phone videos.
What happened was I reached out to him
and he invited me to the heavyweight
factory. Holyfield Phil was there.
Everybody and I just went there a few
times and I created some creative videos
for them to working out. He was,
when I was there, I seen him.
He still looks good. He does
man. He like what? Crazy.
He's like 50 something years
old. He's 50 years. I got some,
I got some amazing stories about like
that I've never released about Tyson fight
like crazy things like his, his,
oh man, I got some stuff. Yeah.
Well initially anatomy, if it was
just supposed to be a documentary,
that was it. And I was that was it
just an hour long documentary? Um,
I never knew who it could be was
and nothing like I just didn't know.
I knew Michael Johnson, all these guys
because they was at the black zillion.
So I knew the first day I ever went
in the gym like Michael Chandler,
C'mon ooze mind. Shout out
to Kumar, who's my, cause I,
the first time I ever saw him
I thought he was a bum. What?
Cause Michael Cherrella gave it to him
and I got it on camera and I thought the
Chandler was the stud. Right.
And then they was like, oh,
he won the ultimate fighter, things like
that. So that was almost two years ago.
You thought he was a bum? Yeah,
just cause I saw the day in the gym,
it was sparring, it was just
sparring. So I'm, you know,
I'm going around filming people and
then I just turned to the cage and like
Michael [inaudible] just dropped
them with like a low shot.
And then Michael Chandler
like walking around them,
like I created this film called
the portrait of the black zillions.
That was like the first thing I ever
made because it was Glenn Robinson rip to
him and Tyrone Spong that
really pushed me to do MMA.
They saw the stuff that I did with
Shannon bricks and they called me into the
office that same day that I,
I gave whoever the manager was at Jocko
to the footage and Glen just said,
listen, we need this type of work in
MMA. Like this is high quality stuff.
And Tyrone spawn was boxing. So I
knew he was probably loving, uh, the,
the footage with Shannon bridge cause he,
he in boxing and that's after he broke
his leg against [inaudible] Saki and he
decided to just go straight to box. So
he, you know, Tyrone, he's very, uh,
persuasive and he was like, Hey,
this, we need this in the gym.
So they gave me a pass to go to a sparring
date and really work out with them.
And, um, yeah, there it is right there.
But uh, yeah, that's how it happened.
And I just kept going to the gym every
day, put that back up chest and that,
okay. Yeah,
that's the first thing I ever filmed in
my life called the portrait of the black
zillions. And that shot of a Michael
Chandler, a RP to Jordan Parsons,
that was a fighter that, you know,
died after getting hit by a car. Um,
but that's the first thing I
ever found for anatomy of fire.
That was the sparring match.
And, um, yeah, that was it.
And from there, uh,
everything was born. Um,
I still was like focusing on
doing like a documentary, um,
until I moved to Vegas. Uh,
like a summer after that during a condom
of Gregor in a Floyd Mayweather fight.
I just wanted to,
I felt like I needed to move to Vegas
cause the energy was taking me there and I
felt like, ah,
if I'm going to do a documentary I
might as well be a Vegas where a lot of
fighters is. This is a
giant shift for you. Right.
So like what were you filming before?
Two years ago when you were at the
Black Zillions? Uh, before that,
like I have a wedding business,
so I was doing weddings.
My big black ass is doing
weddings, which is funny.
I go to these weddings
and people would be like,
cause we'll sit down
was gigantic six, five.
So he's towered over all of these
people, little in their wedding. I,
I really thought like, man, my life
is miserable. At one point I was like,
I'm just shooting these a, yeah,
after a while, like you win or award,
then another ward in another ward and
it's all based off reviews. Right.
And it was like, man, I gotta I
gotta do something more than this.
So I did like basketball
documentaries in Italy. I live,
I lived in Italy for a
minute. I went to China,
did a basketball document Mentari there
because that's my background basketball.
But after that I was just like,
man, what, what else can I do?
And I literally just stumbled. I saw
the gym one day Jocko. And I was like,
that's where dumb black, zillions train.
And I went over there and
that's how all of this started.
Didn't know martial
arts training, nothing.
I just saw the gym and I was like Das
Jocko. I know the black zillions trainer.
So I went in there like mid day, nobody
was in there. And I just said, listen,
I'm a filmmaker. I would love
to film some of these fighters.
And that's cool for that. Yeah.
So I went to college and University of
Southern Indiana and Evansville on a
basketball scholarship.
I was a top senior in America coming out
of high school and I went to this top
division two school after I tried to
wait my senior year to get some division
one offers.
If people know like division one is
the top level of basketball and then
division two is right under that.
Probably not now, but back then it was,
and um, I went, uh,
Bruce Perl was my coach.
He was very persuasive to get me
to come to the university. He,
he coaches at Auburn now. Uh,
they just went to the final four
this year if you know anything about
basketball. But I played my first year
and then going into my second year,
I tore my ACL and uh, I, my life was over.
All I knew was basketball. Anybody
know anything about Carbondale?
It's about 25,000 people.
People don't leave that town.
It's kind of a miserable, you know, thing.
I think like the average household median
income there is like 16,000 a year for
families to use. Yeah. Like,
so you come from the bottom.
Did you get it repaired? Yeah. So
I had surgery, I had the red shirt.
So when you're in college and
you set out in your red shirt,
so one day I was dating this girl and she
was going to Walmart and she literally
was just like, Oh, you want to come to
Walmart with me? And I was like, yeah,
I had some pell grant money
and I was addicted to the, the,
you remember the MTV show,
road rules and real world.
I used to be addicted to that stuff.
So I used to watch it all the time and
I went to Walmart today and bought a
camera. That was my,
a Sony handycam the one you used
to put little mini DV Ds in.
And that was the birth. I literally,
my life changed soon as I bought
that camera and I was like, Oh,
I'm gonna just film my
Rehab and uh, come back.
More ferocious than all I was doing
was like filming girls at parties,
doing bongs and shit like that.
Literally for four years
I had a camera every day.
So you just stopped playing
basketball? No, I can,
I continue to play basketball. I, I
came back a year after my red shirt. Um,
I finish at one of the top five scores
in school history and university history,
top four rebounds all time leader and
field goal percentage, all American.
And my senior year we went to the national
championship, played on national TV.
Everything. After that was done, I wasn't
the same player after I told my ACO.
I can just admit that like I was this
high flying super freak, athletic,
45 inch vertical type of player to,
I couldn't do that anymore so I had to
adjust my whole game. What was wrong?
I don't know. Maybe I just, you know,
it was different back in 2001 right.
So as far as surgery and the
Patella tendon and Patella. Yep.
That's, and they don't do that
anymore. They still do. They do.
Yeah. George Saint Pierre
had that done. Yeah.
They do that sometimes because
they think that the Patella Tendon,
I had it done in 90 no. Yeah,
93 I haven't done on this leg.
And then this one I had the
cadaver, which was way easier.
Cadavers like a six month rehab and I
was back to Jujitsu a hundred percent
I was always like slightly
knocked lead. Right.
And it's like that surgery made my left
knee even more knock and it's like,
that's why I was telling Jamie like I
need that cause I feel like I need to like
strengthen my teammates. Yeah.
Crazy roller thing. What is that thing
called again? Jamie? No role here.
So pull it up Ra. Yeah, I
need something like that.
Jamie's showing everybody. There
you go. That's crazy heavy.
Clamp that thing down your thigh. It
didn't seem that good for my, my cow.
While you were like standing on it,
you gotta like you can't have any
tension on it or whatever. You're like,
oh but your thigh,
it seems like it would be
a lot of pressure because
it's for sure like a spring.
Get a thicker your muscle.
Yeah, it's like a, it's hot.
I don't know how much weight is
pushing on it, but it's a lot.
And you could also push with both side
for sure. Yeah, you can call it that.
Our eight roll recovery, it's like it
said medical grade on the box. I was like,
okay, it's a medical
grade. Like weed. Yeah.
I feel like I need that to like wake
up my left leg still to this day to two
decades later. Did you go through
Rehab and everything? And I did.
I did all that work. So
listen, I recovered fine.
Like my college career was totally fine,
but you just didn't feel, I just did.
Honestly, I lost the love of basketball,
honestly, after filling girls,
that's all I had in my life was
basketball. So once that was gone,
even when I came back it
was, I wasn't the same.
So even though I had games
where I was 25 points,
15 like x, great games, winning
all these awards, all regional,
I, it just wasn't there anymore.
And I hacked this camera that I love to
just have because that year off I was
able to,
I like my first ever film I ever did
was I went around campus and film like
girls asked them who the hottest
athletes was and I felt like they gave me
power, gave me power,
like just to be able to cause back then
that's when girls gone wild was popular.
Oh Wow. Yeah.
That was 2000 gone walk
man, Girls Gone Wild Duck.
Stan hope hosted that at one point
in time. Yeah, that's funny. But,
so I graduated college in 2004 and um,
I moved to Phoenix where my
best friend, Mr Organic and uh,
he was out there just living and I
wanted to get out of my little town.
So I went out there and I,
I kinda wanted to like take a year
off and then try to play professional
basketball because you either play
in the NBA or you go overseas to play
basketball.
So I went to Phoenix with no idea what
I was going to do with my life and I,
I literally started working
at a call center, Amir. Uh,
it was uh, what was that? O f a phone
company that went out of business.
I can't remember what it was called, but
uh, I used to just call people collect,
uh, and try to get them to sign up for
long distance and then you get caught.
Like I, I got caught every
word in the book every day.
But it was funny like people's calling
you the n word and everything and you're
just laughing cause they bad. Right.
And then you like convinced them like
90 year old lady to sign up for long
distance knowing that as illegal
as hell. Like you just convincing,
convincing this lady to
sign up for a long distance.
But I was good at it
though. I was good at it.
So that was like my first
job I ever had in my life.
So it's like one of them shady phone,
they call you up like I get those
Robo calls calls you, you did that.
Like do you want unlimited long distance?
Do you feel guilty? A little bit.
But they went out. They went out of
business. I like six months after I uh,
had the job and I from there I just didn't
know what I was going to do and I had
a, um,
he's not my cousin but he's like
somebody we all call our cousins,
like black people. We call everybody
I cousins but he played in the NBA.
His name was Troy Hudson
and he was from my town.
So he was like the most successful
person that ever got out of our town.
He was playing for the
Minnesota Timberwolves and
I reached out to him cause I
basically was like, listen man,
I need help cause I want to
play basketball again but
I don't know how I'm going
to, I don't have an agent,
I don't have anything.
So he kind of invited us
up to Minneapolis. That's
the first time I lived.
I literally went from Evansville,
Phoenix to Minneapolis to try to
pursue this whole basketball career.
And I did that for like three years.
Like chasing it, going to try outs,
things like that,
sending tapes to agents and things
like that and it just didn't pan out.
Nothing stuck. You know, I
had opportunities, they just,
I just wasn't the same player and I
can admit that and I'm comfortable that
because I know I had a
successful basketball career,
just didn't go to the level where I made
millions of dollars. So after that man,
I was literally stuck after traveling
around the world. I ended up in Malaysia,
I was in Australia trying to Asia,
you don't want to know how I ended
up over here, man. This is funny.
Only a few people know this story. So
when you were at your bottom you
try to find something for comfort.
I've never done weed or
anything in my life, but I,
I was addicted to like
online dating back then. Yes.
I was like trying to meet girls, like
just to try to find some situation.
I felt like, Oh, I feel incomplete. So
let me like online date or whatever.
And I met this girl,
like one of my friends in Phoenix
played basketball in Kuala Lumpur.
So obviously you need a
visa to go over there.
So I'm thinking to myself like what's
stuck the way I could get over there to
Kuala Lumpur and try to play basketball.
So I was like, oh online dating.
I don't even remember what website
or see you're a good looking guy.
I know how you not
getting girls in America.
I do but I'm just saying I was
just listen, my whole point,
my point was I literally met this
girl in Kuala Lumpur, Malaysia.
She was from Canada,
she was a singer over there singing
in little military bars over there.
There's little hot blind or
whatever she was. And um,
I remember talking to her for about a
month and I convinced her that I wanted to
come visit her, but my whole
intention was let me get over there,
try to find out what this team is and
see if I could like try out for him some
crazy shit. You don't do that
today. I did it back then.
So I went over there to,
I'm laughing cause I know
people that know me is dying.
Listening to this right now.
This is a true 100% store.
I get over there to
Malaysia with no money.
I may have $400 I got people
to pay for ticket here.
I'm going to Malaysia to play
basketball. Just lying to people, right?
So I get over there. This girl, I only
want to say her name, she might sue me,
but she picked me up at the airport.
She looked exactly like her pictures.
Beautiful from Canada, everything.
So she take me to her apartment.
She got this nice apartment.
It's like in a jungle chair.
Like I'm talking about the balcony. I
seen like little monkeys on the balcony.
Oh yes. It was crazy. And then
it's like a rain forest. Right?
And then in Malaysia, if
you ever been to Malaysia,
I don't know if it's like that now
the doors are high off the ground,
like two inches. So it's like anything
can crawl under the doors or whatever.
So that's the first thing I noticed
when I got to Malaysia. I was like,
this is some crazy shit, right? We
in the jungle and the dude like,
what about snakes or bugs?
I remember asking these little kids when
I first got to Malaysia, I was like,
have you ever seen a snake like in
this area? And he was like, yeah,
I seen the Cobra and all that stuff.
And I was just like, Holy Shit.
But the back to her, she
turned out to be a sex addict.
Yes. Congratulations man.
Listen, Yo, this is crazy. Like,
because this is way before
I ever decided this,
I'm going to do film for a
living. Right. I was over there,
um, the first day I got there, like
I had a good time with her. Then I,
you know,
ended up having relations with the lady
and she turned out to be a sex addict.
So, you know, as a man,
I just flew all the way across
the world to see this girl.
The sleeve would air and then all of
a sudden she wanted to do it again and
again and again. And then when you
like slow down, like, you know,
I just got her shit bro.
She started crying and going
nuts. And I'm in Malaysia,
I'm like, I don't know who
this girl is. Oh No, listen,
she's crying cause you
won't fuck her again. Yes.
How many times you fucker about
two times that you wanted to yeah,
you too long. The time still
like shit. It was crazy.
So then I even listen, I am in
Malaysia. This, I'm not in America,
I'm in Malaysia.
So the crazy thing is probably after a
week she started to go crazy and complain
about I'm not sleeping with her.
I'm a, I'm in my, I'm in my prime,
my sexual peak and you
don't want to sleep with me.
And I'm just thinking of myself like I
don't know what the fuck am I doing over
here in Malaysia? Like what? This lady.
So I ended up meeting this black guy,
uh, that she introduced me to. There
was like a hustler in Kuala Lumpur,
Malaysia.
And I started hanging out with him just
to get out of the house and he was like
living with, you don't have any
money to go home. Oh my God.
I'm just stuck in Kuala Lumpur and La
with this beautiful girl that you have to
fuck all the time. First of
all problems, right? Serious.
And then she started getting even
bitter. Like, I hate Americans.
You Americans are so ungrateful.
And I'm just thinking like, damn,
wow, you're representing America.
It was crazy. I was like, damn,
I must've just didn't
do a good enough. Sorry.
I thought our girls be lined in right.
Maybe she was just extraordinary.
And she was like in her late thirties
and I was in my early twenties so some
girls in their late thirties, they
hit this itchy peak man all the time.
She ended up skiing or kicked
me out her house in Malaysia.
I went out with Bobby one night.
This dude, his name was Bobby too,
and m w I came home and she
shit, um, your stuff is outside.
Like she texted me, I had a little
international phone. She was like,
your stuff is outside. I'm
thinking like, she was like, yeah,
this is not working out.
So think about that.
Imagine being in another country and
this is not working out. No money,
no money, zero oh not a dime.
And I see the guy that I was with, I
told him what happened. He was like,
I'm gonna take you over
there and get your stuff.
He could stay with me
until you figure it out.
I get there and all my stuff
is outside, everything.
She's not there, she's
done left or whatever.
And I had some brand new timberlands.
Remember the boots templates?
I am poor shit. I need them
timberlands. They in a house.
I had more on brand new. So I kicked
the door down. Boom. Oh No. Yes.
Like I was trying to get into the door.
I just kicked it and it broke
like the little handle broke.
I got in and got my timberlands left.
I remember she texted me, she was like,
Hey, did you break my
door? I was like, Nah,
I don't know what you're talking about.
I just left. So from there I was,
I stayed with Bobby for like
three weeks in Malaysia.
I was hanging out with him everyday
going to parties and I'm like, Bro,
I gotta get home to America. So
I contacted my, one of my, uh,
mentors growing up, uh, in Australia,
he was playing pro professional basketball
in Melbourne name Rashad Tucker.
Shout out to him and I convinced them
to get me a ticket to come over to
Melbourne because I was like,
Bro, I need some money to go home.
And he was like, Nah man, I just get
you a ticket to come to Melbourne.
I was like, Bro, literally like
I'm trying to go back to America.
I don't know what to. But then when
he, he sold me on, I was like, damn,
I really ain't going back to nothing,
so let me go. He was like, man,
you can come over here and try out for
the team. You can try practice with us.
And I was like, oh,
that may be my opportunity to
play professional basketball if I,
he's one of the top players in Australia.
So I ended up in Melbourne and I
was in Melbourne for three months,
not doing shit, but going
out practicing with the team.
They was mid season so I couldn't like
make a team because they was already,
you know,
they think and then I ended up getting
stranded over there too because he left
me cause he cheated on his girlfriend
and uh, he had to go make up with her.
So he left me talking
about I'm going to be back.
And then I was just stuck
in Australia. Like, Yo Bro,
I need to get back to America job. No
job, no money, nothing. He was like,
uh, I'm glad I was young when I did
all this stuff. He was like, hey man,
tell her, tell one of them girls
a sob story. They'll get you a,
I'm like a sob story, Bro. You have
money. Buy me a ticket to go home, man.
I can't do it right now. I'm like, man.
So I had to tell this girl a sob story.
Her name was Deanna, Deanna Casar.
I'm giving her a shot out
because she saved my life.
She bought me a ticket home. She,
she went in her savings and bought
me a ticket back from Melbourne to Ho
Honolulu to Los Vegas. And, um,
I didn't know why I chose Las Vegas,
but I just chose to go to Las Vegas.
So you literally had zero money,
zero micro job. How were you eating?
Shit. Her people that I was around
right. They just fed you. Yeah man.
Sometimes you have angels in your life
and I guess these people were angels to,
cause I was just telling Jamie like I
just seen a documentary on homelessness.
It was like four out of five people
in La County paycheck to paycheck.
I think it was like eight or it's four
out of five people are like one $400
emergency from being broke or it was
like 80% of people live paycheck to
paycheck. So I always
tell people like when,
when I'm inspiring people now I'm
like Bro, I was homeless once.
Cause that's essentially homelessness.
Yeah. If you ain't gotta address,
you can't pay bills. You're homeless no
matter if you got a roof over your head.
And I think, I feel like people,
you see all these beautiful moments
that I do now or what anybody does does,
and they don't see the, the story
that ultimately led, like what,
what ultimately turn to you
doing what you're doing now.
So after Australia I went to Vegas.
I was living with two strippers.
Yes. I live with two strippers.
Graduations again. Yeah,
I'll live in Vegas with two strippers
that worked at the Rhino Despair Rhino.
I met him on Craig lists for
rooms to rent Jesus Christ.
And I had enough money,
like $600 to move into a room.
So I literally moved in with these girls.
And one day, have you ever
been in a Vegas casinos?
Cause this is like the climax you
ever seen like the mega bucks slots.
So one day it was flowy Mayweather
versus Oscar de la Hoya.
So that was the year I was in the,
the Mirage and I seen these two hot black
girls and I had like some money in my
pocket car haunted or something. So
I wanted to sit down next to him.
So I went over there and sat next
to him and was just, you know,
trying to shoot the shit and I put a $20
in the slots cause you know you can get
free drinks if you put in a slot. So
I just hitting it, talking to him,
where y'all from? Y'all going
into fight, blah blah blah.
And then one of the girls was like,
hey you won. I was like, Oh okay.
You know you thinking he ain't went
in those slots. Guess how much I want?
How much? Nah Thousand
Dollars Whoa. Swear to God.
$9,000 till somebody
broke. Wow. Yes. $9,000.
So when they give you that,
do you pay taxes on it later or they all
gave him a wrong social security number
though. You're getting the wrong. So yeah,
I gave him the wrong stuff. They can,
you can do that. Yeah. Cause
they just actually your name,
your social security number. Okay.
Maybe you shouldn't have just
told everybody that they aren't,
they can't prove that I
want anything. They can.
That was like 12 years ago. They
didn't have records back then. Now.
I don't think so. I hope not. Nah, me
too. Ain't nobody gonna Watch this.
Nobody's watching them. And I know this,
this is nobody's gonna want nothing.
So after that, I literally
lived off that, um,
nine grand for about the
rest of the summer. And uh,
I ended up moving to San Diego after
that. Like I'm skipping some stuff,
but I moved to San Diego and that's when
my life changed because I lived in San
Diego and was just partying.
What brought you to San Diego?
I met a guy in Vegas during the,
the night of the Floyd Mayweather fight
and just party with him that night and I
just got his phone number one time and
then I was just staying in touch with
them or whatever. And then he was like,
I live in San Diego. He was in the Navy,
Dr Bill. And um, I literally said,
let me come out there
one weekend. I was like,
let me just come out there and
kick it with you or whatever.
Cause he was telling me how
great San Diego was and I'm,
I went out there and I
didn't leave for four years.
San Diego was pretty awesome.
Yeah. I love San Diego but I,
I essentially was doing the same thing
I was doing for the past couple of years
lost cause you gotta understand
like athletes go through this now.
Like I just did,
I just released the episode where Ryan
Bader on my channel and I talked to him
about that. Like when, when
your sports career is done,
a lot of people go to something
else they lost and things like that.
And I was for about four or five years
and it wasn't until I lived in San Diego
that I figured, I was like, man, I
gotta really do something with my life.
I'm literally a failure. I
got, I have a college degree.
I graduated from college.
So it wasn't like I just didn't want that
responsibility of having to do a nine
to five or and things like that.
So it wasn't until I live in San Diego
that I literally talked to the guy that I
was living with him and was like, Bro, I,
I don't know what I'm
gonna do with my life bro,
but I gotta figure something out.
I was like nearing 30 and um,
I ended up moving to Minneapolis back
to Minneapolis and I got a job as a
teacher, like a teacher's assistant
and they called it behavior system.
I was like working with kindergarten kids
to Jesus. Literally crazy life. Right?
What a crazy life ended up where I'm at
now to be on Joe Rogan. Right. So it,
it was March 3rd to 2011. Um,
it was like negative 20 degrees
outside. I was living with my guy,
my best friend, and I'm,
I went to work that day and it was
freezing outside and they literally still
went to recess that day. I'll never
forget that. They was like, Oh,
put your coats and gloves on kids.
It's time to go to, to recess.
And I was like, what do you mean
we going into the gym or outside?
It's like we're going outside. I was
like, man, these people in Minnesota,
crazy hard. Those are hard people, Bro.
That was the last day I ever worked
in my life. He said, fuck this.
I can't do it, man. I was like, Bro,
that whether it was just the fact that I
was like, what am I doing with my life?
I'm working with Kenneth, the great,
rewarding job. I'm like, what?
It's nothing wrong with me. I'm
physically able to do anything.
I'm intelligent enough to do anything.
I'm qualified enough to do anything.
You're a victim of circumstance.
Victim just kept happening.
Things kept happening. Um, and
a lot of it is my fault. Like,
because you're just lazy, right?
So March 30 2011 is the day I,
I said I'm quitting my job. I went
back to my apartment when my roommate,
he was pissed. He was like,
Bro, you always quitting
jobs. And he was like, Bro,
what you going to do? I was like, Bro,
I'm, I'm Finna figure something out.
I'm going to buy a camera to do something.
He was like, yeah, yeah, whatever.
And,
and we literally was sitting
in the kitchen in this
little kitchen on the floor
talking about life. Cause I would
just tell, I literally mentally broke.
I was like, Bro, I'm just Jack.
Like I got to figure something out.
I had pell grant was coming up,
I was getting my tax returns back and I
had enough to buy a camera and the first
camera I ever bought was a canon t to die.
It was like $800 and I bought a
lens and that was it. That was it.
It changed my life.
And I literally spent like the next
year shooting videos in garages,
like cars coming up, filming the wheels.
And I was just really literally hone in
myself because back then when I had a
camera in college,
digital cameras wasn't even out until
2008 like these little new style cameras.
So I had to relearn everything. And I,
I really learned a lot from youtube
and Vimeo and I was watching the,
I had a creative eye and a
mindset. So I was just like,
I got to get the skillset.
So I started doing rap videos
for $50 a hundred dollars free.
You know, I tell all these kids,
they messaged me now like, Bro,
I spent two years on videos for free,
just trying to learn how to do this stuff.
Everybody want to get paid
for something. And I'm like,
you probably don't deserve
to get paid yet. So I,
I had friends shout out
to Matt, Irv, Mr Organic,
like I was shooting a videos for
free and I was just getting better.
I was getting better and
better and better and better.
And then like three years into it,
I shot a music video called Saks fifth
avenue and I'm see you're editing these
as well. I'm editing, I'm doing
them all you editing on, uh,
at the time I was editing
on Sony Vegas, uh, uh,
old program. Now it's, it's,
it's, it's popular now.
It's pretty easy to use and um,
it was cheap to buy like 90 bucks.
So I was able to use that. Um,
like the movie studio version that was,
you don't get all the little tools,
but you got enough. And I
had this cheap laptop, uh,
that this girl bought me a, she lied and
told me she was gonna buy me a camera.
They ended up buying me a laptop.
I was pissed off and I was like,
she was like, listen,
like the most popular a
camera back in like 2011.
It was like a canon five d
mark two. It was like $2,000.
I couldn't afford that.
So I met this girl online
literally from Denver, Colorado,
from Denver, Colorado. And you know,
you start your little love affair or
whatever you talking and you promising and
I want to see you. So one day she was
like, I'm gonna come see you in Minnesota.
This is around the time I started. And uh,
she told me she was going to buy me that
camera cause I was telling you that's
like my dream camera, my Jean Camera.
And I remember my roommate, uh,
like I'll run in his room like, look bro,
look at his short film that was shot with
this camera. I'm Finna had his camera,
Bro. We Finna do all types of things.
So she like kept telling
me she had the camera,
kept telling me he had the camera. So
like the day she came, I picked her up.
I had this little use nine 1992
for tours. It was blue and uh,
I picked her up at the airport. I
remember I was like, where the camera at?
As soon as soon as she picked me up where
the camera, she was like, don't worry,
don't worry, don't worry. And I'm
like driving thinking like, man,
she ain't got this camera. She lied to
me. She just wanted to see me. Right.
So we get to my apartment and my boy,
he anticipating it too. He like, man,
he finna get this. Can we finish?
Shoot all their music videos, right.
Cause if you get this camera at this
time, you, oh you shooting at a five d.
So I remember she like pulled,
she was like, here's a gift.
It's like she pulled out the gift and
I was like, this ain't no camera box.
It was a brand new laptop. And
I'm sitting here complaining,
I'm complaining about a laptop
and I already have a camera.
But she like gave me this laptop and
I was just like, all right, cool.
So she gave me the laptop and I,
I get the Sony Vegas program and then I
started editing with that and I had that
camera for about two years. I
was in the girl, I don't know,
there's a lot of that in my life and
I don't blame them. Girls. Listen man.
Yeah. I used to be one of those
guys, you know, Dum, Dum girls,
this materialistic and he all about nice
things and he liked to travel or you
ever dated a girl and you like see her
previous boyfriend and they be like,
damn,
they don't want to like Napa Valley and
fucking Vegas for her birthday or a New
York. And you're like, damn, I can't
even take you to the movies. I'm like,
Damn. So for me, if a
girl get tired of you,
now they call it ghosting, right? They
call it ghosting. But back then ghosted,
that's what ghosting was. It's like,
oh, this guy ain't worth nothing.
Let me get rid of him.
So she left, she left.
I had a summer job.
My last ever official job was at 43 hoops
in Minnesota was a basketball academy
where I was there with a lot
of pro basketball players
or semi-pro or guys that
had college experience and we just
taught kids all the time. And um,
I was getting paid, you know,
$20 an hour or $25 an hour
per session to teach kids.
And I kind of made a Ruckus. They're
two complaining about just Bro,
we teach in 20 kids and
I'm only getting $20.
How much are y'all getting
for all these kids? Right.
But I mean that's just work, right?
I shouldn't complain about a job,
but that whole summer I was
just telling everybody in here,
I'm going to do film. I'm
moving back to California.
I'm about to just do film about
to do film because I had enough,
like I was doing videos at that point,
but now I have a part time job that I'm
able to do videos and I never forget.
One day I was telling a
group of guys in there,
I'm quitting this job
and I'm Finna go do film.
And I just remember the look on their
face like you know like the boy that cried
wolf, whatever, man,
you ain't going to do anything but
that drove me and St Joe doubt,
doubt drove things out, people
doubted me. That's what I needed.
I needed that fueled where people
could tell me I couldn't do any.
You needed haters.
I needed haters and it drove me insane
and I went nuts and I started shooting a
lot of music videos that any videographer
out there that didn't knows this
industry, they know like music videos
feed you, you make a lot of money.
It's a recession proof business. People
always going to need music videos,
especially rap videos. And
I got good, I got very good.
I did a lot of high profile
videos. I made a lot of money.
Who did you doing for? I did a music
videos for like rappers, like chief Keef,
you know? Yeah. Yes. He
did his videos. Yeah.
It seemed like you'd have to wear a
bulletproof vest to be around that.
There was a video called traffic.
You got to check that out. Oh, okay.
I think I've seen that. It's that you
wild on the streets. Oh, I would imagine.
Wow. They're legitimately wild.
That was real gangster shit going on
with your Chicago rappers and stuff like
that. Well that dude is like
the king of that Shit. Right?
It's only like 20 right. I
think now he's getting 20 Nah,
he probably like 2124 now.
Yeah, they was kids man.
But I was shooting a lot of music videos
in Minneapolis and I got popular cause
that's a huge music scene. It's a very
indie, you know, prince made it popular,
but I think the hip hop scene is
very in rich at. They just don't,
they haven't had anybody
like explode out of there.
So I made a living just in Minneapolis,
like shooting music videos.
But after a while, I remember I was dating
this girl and this one lasted a bit.
And I remember I used to brag to
her like, look at his music video,
this music video. And she was like,
you want to just be known
for doing music videos?
You want to be a guy that just do music
videos, you need to do other stuff.
And that's what woke me up. I was like,
let me see if I can tap into my
creative side and do other things.
So I did like a film called like
the confessions of skid row.
I would literally went to skid row and
filmed homeless people I don't want Yup.
And I'm not available yet. It's
somewhere on the line. Online.
Real freaks me out. Yeah. It was
called the confessions skid row.
And then I did, it was cool. I
was like, I'm gonna make this,
this series called the confessions.
And then I did the confessions of Gay
Pride and I literally interviewed this guy
in San Diego about how, when
Obama passed a don't ask,
don't tell. Like I, I
interviewed this guy, um,
and he told me how he came out
to his parents and I'm like,
I know my boys just look at me
like what the Carol do you doing?
Like these types of films. But I was
fascinated by documentaries so I was like,
let me just do this type of documentary
content doing the one on skid road.
Did that have like an extra impact on you
because you were basically home? Yeah,
100% I told, I told the guy I was like,
I was literally homeless so I know what
she feels like and I don't think people
understand that. Like if
I look at my life now,
I live in downtown l a view of the
staple center, things like that.
Like they don't understand.
Years ago I didn't have,
I couldn't afford to live in a $400 a
month apartment. You see what I'm saying?
Cause you didn't have any guaranteed
income and that's how it was.
Even the beginning of my film career I
lived out at like you know them shitty
hotels I why are they not shitty to
everybody but like extended stays. Yeah.
I lived in extended stays for
like two years. Literally.
Like I say I was getting a $400 for a
music video from a rapper or something
like that. I will use 200 of that
for six days in extended state.
Cause you know there was like $30 a
night. It'd be nights where I'm like damn,
I got one day left.
I got to convince somebody to give
me like $200 to shoot a music video.
So I was hustling, like reaching
out to people on Facebook. Hey Man,
you try shooting music video,
you're trying to day not knowing I
need this money to just live somewhere.
Wow.
So once I was able to sustain enough
income because it's just too long of a
story,
but I was able to really get myself to
a point where I was making some money.
I moved to Florida where my
best friend tone from Macedonia,
six foot nine Macedonian mercenary.
That's where he wanted to be.
Like he a crazy guy.
Like he wants to like go around the
world and kill like drug dealers.
That's literally he from Macedonian
man. They crazy man. They crazy.
So brother tone.
I moved in with him in Boca Raton
and that's literally has started.
That's how all of this and that email
fighter stuff started. I moved to Florida,
live with him. I had a roommate,
so it was cheaper to live.
I went to Italy that year
and shot a documentary.
So I got some money from my Guy
Bobby Jones. And um, I was able to
have a life. I felt comfortable.
I wasn't like, felt like a, a a
monkey was on my back at that point.
Um, you getting momentum?
I got momentum. Um,
I had a lot of momentum at that
point. About 2014 I was making money.
So when you were doing
these documentaries,
like confessions of skid row
and confessions at Gay Pride,
like what are you doing with them and
how are you getting paid from them?
Just releasing them online for free will
and then I didn't get paid for anything
I paid. I paid like I paid like the
homeless guy to let me talk to them.
They gotta be on Vimeo. They gotta be in.
You put them on Youtube and
get the ad revenue from. Yeah.
That was back in the day though. But
there, are they out there right now?
Like no, I have, I have a great
one. If you know Alan Watts. Yes.
So it's called the beauty of
nothing is by Allen Watson.
If you put the beauty and nothingness
by Allen Watson Will Harris,
you'll see one of the most beautiful
homeless films you ever seen.
That was like three years ago. I
went to New York. I was here in La,
I was in Florida. I was just sitting
on the streets for homeless people,
talking to them for a, for two days.
And is it Alan Watts narration?
He is the beauty or nothingness. It
like won the award in New York. Well,
when I first saw, I don't remember what
video I saw of yours. That was first,
but I was like, this guy has got an eye
for shit. You, you, it's not the stamp.
You know, sometimes you can see videos
and you're just watching a video.
Like okay, this is cool. I'm
seeing how these guys are training.
I'm seeing their lifestyle, what
I'm seeing. You know their family,
but then you see one and you go,
oh whoever the fuck is filming us,
they know what they're doing. Yeah.
That's what I got from you well was
cause I look at all the Shit I've been
through. Yeah, you shut. That's
also your focus. Like you, you,
you have a vision. Like it's
very clear that you're an artist.
Like when you're doing these videos,
it's not simply you're filming things
like you're thinking about 100% about the
angles, how to edit it, what,
what, you know, how to have a vote.
People talking, you hear their
voice while they're there,
mounts not moving because
they're talking from another,
you know what I'm saying? Then
when you did narration? Yeah.
When you see things that where someone
puts it together and like it makes it
richer, makes it more interesting.
And did you ever hear of a documentary
called Hoop Dreams? Yes, it was a,
that was my high school life.
Like they were older than me,
but when I was in high school
that film came out, uh,
that fascinated me and I was like,
I want a documentary and documented
somebody for five years, followed a life.
I was obsessed. And then my favorite
documentary of all time is pumping iron.
Oh, of course. So when I saw
that in college, I was like,
I want to shoot documentaries. Ah. So I
was always obsessed with documentaries.
Like, I don't know if you remember back,
you remember banging in Little Rock?
Yes. Whew. Yes. That was an HBO,
right. Banging a little. All those,
that's what I like. I don't like
movies. I like documentary on me too.
So for me, I've always was
obsessed with docs. I'm like,
if I can ever shoot a doc, I know
where that passion come from.
So when I literally moved to Florida,
like I literally just reached out to
Shannon Briggs one day. I was like,
cause I was doing weddings
and music, Saas make money,
especially with weddings.
I would make a lot of money with
weddings cause that's just, I mean,
people get married every weekend.
Right? So I mean you can get,
and if you get good enough you can
get three, $4,000 a wedding video. So,
I mean I'm booking two a week. I
started to get to a point where I'm,
let's go chair. That's one. Yeah,
that's the one of him. That's the one.
So that was, that was three years
ago. The podcast I did with him. Yeah,
of course. Yeah. Here's court called
portrait of a boxing gym. Ah, yeah.
So like he's a fucking
care. Who is the guy. Dot.
Deontay Walder knocked out Bur
Berman. Starvation. Uh, yes.
The Vern stubborn. Yeah. That was the,
I remember he was in there that day.
So I would,
I used to do stuff like this before I
ever decided to do anatomy and fight
daunted. Deontay wilder knocked out.
You've got to say everybody fought. Yeah,
that's true. 40 knockouts. 41
upon the craziest fucking records.
Tyson fury too. Well, basically
10 seconds. Yeah. No you didn't.
That's my drink. Listen,
if you ask me who my dream guest is
on anatomy of a fighter Deontay one,
I would love to do a behind the
scenes fight companion with you guys.
Just being here with the camera
filming y'all motherfuckers talking.
That's what the fight
companion is now. Now, now,
but out in the hallways because
Eddie Bravo, bring them here.
Bring some crazier seasoned. Well,
hopefully Eddie tried to
get away from hopefully.
Hopefully I get any bravo on the day
with cheeto. Veryyeah you'll get him on.
Yeah. More Cheetos fight
is canceled. Right? I know.
So they tried to give him
a replacement opponent.
I was hoping that they shot
up to cheat over there. Yeah.
He love your show about I love him. Uh,
he, I'm tough motherfucker. He is. He a,
I was hoping he got to not love
sugar shine. I love both of them.
I love how he taken it to. Yeah,
he taken it because you know,
I seen a lot of people online
talking about, you know,
are they gonna move the car to
enter harm now? He was like, Nah,
they ain't doing that for chicken
shine. Don't know. He got a,
he got a tainted supplement. It's,
it's these new studies or
these new tests that they have.
They are so fucking extensive.
They catch shit that you
did years ago. That's crazy.
And if you took a tainted supplement
with something that has zero performance
benefit years ago, it can
still show up in your system.
Whereas they used to have like, oh,
it'll be out of your system in six weeks.
Like especially talk to like a gym
professor. Like there's a lot. Look,
there's a lot of cheating
in professional sports.
There's a lot of cheating for sure. Like
a lot of cheating and MMA a lot,
but less than they used to be because of
you Sada and Novitsky and what the UFC
is implemented 100% there's a lot of less,
but supplements are a dirty business.
I know this firsthand firm on it from
being one of the owners of on it and not
even supplements tainted
with things that are illegal.
When we first started making Alpha
brain, we had it independently tested.
We get all our shit third
party tested and we were like,
what the fuck is this doing in there?
We had stuff in there that's not supposed
to be in there and well it turns out
when you get stuff made,
like say if you have a,
you put together some sort of a,
a pre-workout trick and you want to have
vitamin B 12 and all these different
things
in it, you get those mixed
by a third party lab.
This lab mixes it all for you, but you
don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They're [inaudible], they're
not cleaning out their shit.
So they might've been doing steroids
right before they do your shit and you're
having to make mix. You have some creotine
and your creatine has Austrian in it,
which is like, well what is it? Some
kind of steroid, I don't know what it is.
It's some kind of steroid.
I was talking to a bodybuilding micro
sheet about supplements cause you know,
obviously he a bodybuilder and
he has a company, I think he,
he works with trifecta too or something
like that. And I was just like, how do,
how does that happen? Like
these tenants supplements.
And I interviewed him about it.
I'm gonna release it one day,
how he goes into it. But you know,
with bodybuilders they catch
flack because they bodybuilders,
you've gotta be on something.
But these guys know they shit.
He has a legitimate business.
So I'm sure he does go.
Most of them are on something like if
you want to get to the size of like a Lee
Haney, you don't get that big without
steroids. It's not a human size.
You know when you get
to like, um, you know,
just go back and look at
like Franco Colombo. Oh Man.
Oh my God. You know, but, but then you
look at like Frank Zane, Frank Zane.
You can get that body without
steroids. What about possible?
What about a Francis, Francis and Ghana.
If he started to be a bodybuilder,
he gotta be gigantic. Yeah,
there's naturally, there's natural
Komatsus. Mine is a freak. Yeah.
Woodley's they freaks. Rock listeners
are freak. There's freaks. There's, look,
there's girls with giant tits. They're
born with triple f tits. Does that works?
Some guys have 20 inch decks.
This is just how the world works.
Some people have big
noses. The world's weird.
I wouldn't want to have a 20 inch
dick though. No, it's too big.
Imagine saying that. I'm too big. You
can't complain though. You can't complain.
Eight and nine is good though.
You know how many dudes are crying
out there with a three inch deck?
They'd be like, oh no.
17 more inches. Yeah,
that's better off having a 20
inch stick than a three inch deck.
Did you just find a girls had
like eight kids and just record.
It'd be weird like, listen,
we want to know another,
another funny online story of my
life. These was all in the past,
but I remember dating this older lady
and she was like, Oh, I'm a freak.
I'm a freak. I'm a freak.
And I was like, how much?
Like she went in her drawer and pulled
out like a Dildo that was like 20 inches.
I was like, Oh, like a horse
cock. And I was just like,
what the fuck am I do with this?
I did everything in my power drop.
She didn't feel shit. I
got mines though, Joe.
I believe you. I believe. Hey, some
weirdos out there, man. Oh, we all weird.
In a way. Yes, everyone. We all listen.
Vegans are weird people that say
they don't drink or weird, uh,
people that only eat nuts
and berries, a weird,
we always aware Christians are weird.
Can't judge nobody. I'll be like, oh,
I never smoked a weed in my life.
But then I'd be online dating.
That's when Weirdos, she's
never smoked weed ever. Never.
Not one time, I'll come drink a
little bit, maybe five times a year.
How come you never smoked weed?
Um, I had an addictive family.
Uh, like I seen it and it was, it
was embarrassing and, and struggling.
Like my mom was 14 years old when she
gave birth to me and my mom was born the
same month I am. So she was
born May 3rd are born May 19th.
So she could have had me at 13.
My Dad was the same age so I didn't
grow up in any parents. Right.
I mean you know your parents, I hate
hearing it but I don't know my dad,
um, at all. I may have two on either.
I may have talked to him twice.
And the only, the last con, you know,
the last conversation
I ever had with my dad,
he had got out of prison and I was
living with his mom. My Grandmother,
the one that raised me and
he like overtook the room
that I was living in cause
it's his room again. Like, I'm
a grown ass man telling his son,
oh Jason and I found his porn
tapes and me and my best friend,
like I knew, I was like, Yo,
you want to watch some porn?
So I like went up in the closet,
took out the tape, put it in,
and then I heard them coming in the house.
So we ran and put the tape back and this
is how precise he was with his porn.
Probably. He noticed some clothes
moves. So we like left the house.
He came out the house, hey, stay out
of my room. I said, man, shut up.
You're a grown man watching
porn. It was my dad.
That's like the last
conversation at Radford. Wow.
He had been in prison in and out his
life. That's the thing. It's like,
listen man, everybody can pick, make
a picture out to be poor me. Yeah,
I don't, that's not me. You, me telling
you all this stuff ain't poor me.
It's just real. It's just life. Right.
Where I'm at now is beautiful. You know,
I was filming videos to survive and then
I finally found something that stuck.
I never in my fucking life thought it
was going to be MMA. Never easy. Never.
So you,
you saw people with addiction problems
and you just didn't want to have anything
to do with it? Nah, I just, yeah, I
just thought it was luckily for me, man,
I found sports and in the fifth
grade and I just was upset.
I have an addictive personality, whether
there's masturbation or anything.
Right. It was very similar
situation. You know what's crazy?
I've seen when he like what's fascinating
about this podcast is that if you go
to your channel on Youtube and
you go to click oldest videos,
that's why I'm not in a rush for
anything because everything takes time.
I looked at like one of your podcasts
with Eddie Bravo like three hours long.
He got like 11,000 views. Oh yeah, yeah.
Like 20,000 views. I want to say like,
hey, how do I get paid from podcasts?
I'm like dude, them for six years. Yeah.
I didn't get paid at all for years.
I mean this podcast is almost 10 years
old and I didn't really start getting
paid like five years ago. And
it's fascinating to see that,
like you go look at your oldest
videos, 20,000, 30,000 views. Yeah.
And that's the thing, like MMA fans are
fickle, right? They like who they like,
they don't like, they like, it's
only about three or four fighters.
They could get a lot of
views, but then you tense.
It's that way with everything.
That's what I'm saying. Yeah.
And people are fascinated. Like
I'm lucky enough to know a Khabib.
Right. Or somebody like that.
Like I didn't know who this guy was
until Rashad Evans was like, Yo,
let me introduce you to my Guy Ali.
And then I met Ali filming some
Henzel Gracie stuff for him. Um,
and he was like, Yo, I like you man.
Let me put you together with my fighter.
You know, who could be. And I was like,
is that they kind of fought Michael
Johnson. I didn't know who could be was.
He was like,
I think y'all would be a good fit because
the way you do stories and stuff like
that, I think you'll hear
like you and you're like him.
I literally met him of January
of last year of 2018 in Boston.
Um, and when Francis Find Steve Pay and
Vulcan was fighting DC and that was the
first time I ever met her. And the rest
is history. I, I filmed him up there.
He was Finna fight Tony. Um,
then I found them during the
whole Connor fiasco, Al Quinta.
Then I went to Dagestan. I went to
Dagestan. What's that like? Intense.
But it was,
it was beautiful because people tried
to scare me when I was supposed to go to
Dagestan who like I got people
in the UFC, they was like, Yo,
be careful over there.
I'm thinking like people that work for
the UFC just stand like, be careful.
Like, and I'm thinking to myself
like, am I dms on Instagram? Like Bro,
just be careful. They don't fucking
play over there. I was going through,
I went during Ramadan last June
at the end of Ramadan. And uh,
did you have to observe
while you were there? So, uh,
could be wanting me to come during like
the last tail end of Ramadan. Right.
So I went over there, um, by myself.
Went and got my visa in Miami and went
over there, just got my ticket. And um,
I went over there. I remember
the first day I got there,
I was in like customs for like two hours
cause they couldn't speak English at
this little airport in,
in Dagestan and Cubby was outside and he
wouldn't come into the airport cause he
too famous. Right. And this
is in the middle of the night.
And I remember when I first got there, uh,
it was just checkpoints
everywhere when I got there.
Like we like drive down the street
person with some guns. I'm like,
alright cool. We're, I don't know where
we at but this is Dagestan. And um,
I ended up getting to this, this, I
stayed at his uncle house I think.
And from there it was, it
was just a beautiful moment.
The Dagestan chronicles is my most
popular thing on my channel obviously,
cause it's Sean could be even a
way no one's ever seen them. Um,
I observed Ramadan the whole time I was
there. I didn't eat, I didn't drink.
I did exactly what could be and them did
because I think a problem with us a lot
as Americans is we take our
culture somewhere else and
I wanted to observe their
culture and really see what it
was like and I was fascinated.
I wanted to know why women
covered themselves and I
asked all those questions.
All of that stuff is in the documentary
and now when I get all these millions of
people watching these videos,
the most common thing is like where
is the women at? And I'm like,
why are these people so obsessed
with where the women at?
And I literally went into that.
Like I asked like when you,
when these women are married, you
don't point a camera at these people.
Like I've seen women, you just don't
point a camera at them. It's rude. Right.
And that's like then their
culture and their culture.
Did they explain this to you? Did, what
did they say? They literally just said,
they look at w like I talked to a couple
of them, a couple of people over there,
and he was just like,
we look at our woman is women as
Queens and we cover him because in, in,
in, in the Koran is, you know,
the man is weak to the flesh.
So they don't want their
woman to be, you know,
looked at by other men things. Yeah.
That's the word I was looking for.
So you just covered themselves up. Um,
and in our culture that's, you know,
they may be weird, but I respect it.
Like what they told me, it made sense.
It literally made sense where
it was just like, listen,
we don't let another man
look at our wife. Right.
I'm not going to bash on that culture
because I feel like that's silly. I want,
we can do whatever they want to do.
That's just how they feel. Like I don't,
you know, so, but I seen women,
I seen some beautiful women
too while I was in Dagestan.
So it wasn't the fact that I didn't
film any women. I seen women,
but they explained to you when you go
here, you cannot film the women. No, no,
no. It was just, yeah, in a way,
like just don't film another man's woman.
Like I think I talked to Chris
Weiman once a, when I was at his gym,
when I was doing I laquinta he,
he went to Chechnya. Yeah. And uh,
he told me a story,
I think him and four of them went to
Chechnya and he was telling me a story of
like, he accidentally touched
on woman's hand and uh,
they like literally got on like
you don't touch another woman,
you don't touch a woman's hand over
here cause that's bad on her. Right.
And I was like, damn,
that's crazy you came.
Cause he said he was just like reaching
out, shaking people's hands, you know,
human instinct, you reach and grab
somebody's hand. And he just said, man,
that that's different culture over there.
You see a woman can't touch
another man's hand. So yeah,
that guy from Chechnya, the, the leader
of Chechnya, he's like really into MMA.
Right? He flies no
people out yet. You know,
what's crazy is that I don't know
anything about the guy or his politics or
anything, but I know that he
obsessed with fighting. Right.
I know Tyler Spong been over there
and why men and all these guys,
I just met nick the tooth the
other day and they went up,
they went over there to Chechnya,
him and amended his brother's
a there. That's the injury too.
Yeah, they had, I think the men,
his brothers had like a
seminar or some seminar. I,
I did like a preview of Cheeto Vera
and he was talking about it and they're
like, they did a Jujitsu match in
front of some oligarch over there.
Like it's crazy. Right? Like they
flew him over there for that. Yeah.
That's got a lot of money. Yeah. OP, Hey,
I'm not even fighting these sponsors.
Didn't need to give, could be like
some crazy Mercedes when he won.
I think I started an
Instagram. You got like a gift.
I think he gave him some crazy s-class
[inaudible] getting that Dubai money now
though, he always in Dubai. Listen, I
mean, since it's fight, even in Dubai,
how many times, what's he doing over
there? Speaking, things like that. I mean,
when you one of the most famous,
I think he's like top 15 and most
famous athletes now. Both for sure.
And definitely the most famous
Muslim athlete. Yeah. Yes.
So I mean he the only UFC champion
that's undefeated other than John Jones,
who should be undefeated if
it not for that one. Listen,
fucked up disqualification.
I have to spend a time what could be
been daggy Stan like me and his father
going into the mountains and things like,
I just don't see nobody beating him.
I'm sorry, what you throw at
them? You don't walk away.
I just feel like just his
pedigree of where he from,
it's nothing that's going to
break that guy. It's you can't,
what are you going to do it? I just
don't think there's nothing you can do.
After going to Dagestan and seeing how
those people live and how that Derrick,
their code and their values and how
they live. What was so convincing?
Well,
just how strict that faith is over there.
Right? And they tie in everything
they do to their faith.
It's sort of like how Ali was like,
I'm not going to lose because
I lie and things like that.
And I truly believe that after seeing
like just the camaraderie over there,
the gyms they train in the mountains,
everything that makes this guy,
it's nothing in the octagon that someone
is going to do like this is going to
beat. Could be like everything
can happen, a fluke can happen.
We see it all the time.
But I just feel like mentally there's
nothing that's gonna Break Khabib.
Like if, I feel like if he was ever
in a situation where he had to tap,
he wouldn't like he would, he would
just have to put him to sleep.
Cause I just don't think that's
possible. Like to beat him.
I honestly feel like it
could be, you can't lose,
I just don't see nobody
beating him. I just,
I've been in locker rooms are
fighters and you got a butterfly.
I fell in and things like that.
Like when he fought Connor and I
was in a locker room, could be,
was facetiming his people in Dagestan
laughing and Javier Mendez is like,
let's get focused, let's get
focused, let's get focused. Could be,
he was not caring. Wow. Could be
just ready to go. Right. When, uh,
Tony Ferguson was fighting pedis,
he like hitting Mitts with Javier and I
could be just looking up to the screen.
Javier is like, let's get folks like
his focus can be, you don't care man.
It's a different level. He always
said that's like his favorite thing.
This is a different level and
that's what I love about him, man.
It's like people are
obsessed with the fighter.
I like to beaver as a person and that's
the thing that I get out of this anatomy
of a fighter. It's like just
hanging out with his guy.
But like if you ever watch my series,
I never really talk about
a guy's fight coming up.
Like if you ever watch anatomy and
fight, it's not about your opponent,
it's just about your life. Because I
felt like when I created it, I felt like
these organizations wasn't promoting
fighters all the way and not, yeah,
they gonna promote the top
fighters and things like that.
But what about the guys that are two and
one in the UFC not ranked like they in
the UFC. Like they may get
cut after a couple of fights,
like what did they have left
after that? And I was just like,
let me create the series instead of a
documentary and just continue to build
this and follow these guys' lives.
And that's all I really wanted to do.
It was no hidden incentive
where I was like,
I'm gonna make millions
of dollars off this.
I'm going to end up on the Joe
Rogan podcast. It was like,
I love following these fighters and
telling their stories because it's sorta
like similar to my journey,
you know, these guys are,
what was the guy that just fought,
um, Dhahran win in Greenville?
Eric Spicy or spice Lee or whatever his
name was. He tweeted like, oh, I had,
he just got, they got fighting
in the night. He was like,
I had two minus two 70
in my bank account. Yeah,
I been there Joe. So that's why I,
I'd get the passion out of doing it
cause I been there with these fighters.
I at this point in my life,
I've paid for fighters,
flights and hotels because
they couldn't get a hotel.
Like these fighters know that some of
these fighters know that to where I'm able
to help them. And I, I'm finding
this all on my own breaking myself.
So I'm to me,
I'm just thinking about myself like
you doing this for a specific reason,
you passionate about it and you want to
tell these guys' lives and I just really
want it to offer another glimpse into
fighter slots other than fight week.
And Are you getting paid
from Youtube revenue? Yeah,
my account is moaning to not Mona
Tonies and verify. Yeah. Monitor,
monetized and verified.
And depending on a month,
it can be a good month.
It can be a bad month. Um,
it's surprising to me. I
haven't got a sponsor yet.
Like it's popular as the channel is,
but it is what it is now. Probably.
Who knows.
I mean shout out to like people like
eight minutes strong like you know,
then that's Ryan Bader. Stephanie. Yeah,
that's Ryan Bader. Shout out to Adam,
the owner of it and his brother,
like they was the first people to
ever send me stuff like t shirts.
I was just happy. I was like, damn, I
got some free gear. Right? Like man.
Finally I remember seeing they shirts
back when I first started with Kamala
whose mom was wearing stuff. And
you know, companies like that,
you get money here and there from them,
but like to sustain this like member
fight land, remember to show white land.
I heard they went out of business
because the funding wasn't advice.
It's something like that.
It's company because out they went
out of business because of funding.
Vice probably just decided to stop
doing it. Listen Joe, you travel.
But vice's a billion dollar company.
That's true. What they believe.
Fight landers advice show, isn't
it? What's fun up? Yeah, pretty,
pretty sure fight. Lynn was vice.
If you flew to Phoenix for
three days to do comedy,
um, and get a hotel and you know
how expensive flight and like,
so imagine me funding this on my own if
I want to go somewhere for three days,
especially Dagestan yeah, shit like that.
And where are you staying when your
entire staff? I was staying with US state.
It could be Eve's family house.
Oh Wow. Yeah. So I stayed a,
they put me like above
a store and he told me,
he gave me a key. He was like,
brother locked this door at night,
brother Jesus Christ. He
was like, don't go outside.
I still went outside. Did you?
Yeah, I still went outside. You Go.
I just was roaming like walking
around, just filming stuff.
What's it like out in Dagestan
when you're roaming the street?
They never really seen
black people over there.
So I was like a little celebrity
over there and you're a big one.
And they know I'm from, I'm Waco
Beach, so I was cool with that.
So they knew that. Yeah. You know,
you get me. Yeah. They was Chitlin.
Did they speak English? A couple
people did. Yeah. A couple people did.
Did they ask you questions? Yeah, they
asked me questions. They, you know, they,
they obviously I had already been with
Khabib at that time, you know, I was,
that was past the Conor
McGregor fiasco. So you know,
my channel get popular cause
it's something like that.
And they just watched anything
could be related. Could be,
you've got some crazy fans, man. How
many people live in Duggan style? Man,
I don't know Jimmy. Pull that up. I said,
just want to say that
I saw some of the videos of people
celebrating when he wanted it was fucking
crazy, man.
It was treats are honking their horns
and when he won the title or when he econ
or would it be Connor? And that was
crazy. 2.9 million. Yeah. Okay, cool.
So, um, so it's your, you're, it's a city,
but it's essentially like this
big, the mountains. Yeah, it's big.
The mountains are like right next to
it or something like sorta like when we
went to his mountain village, we had
to drive like two hours to get there.
Oh really? Yeah. Like we had to
go on the borders of Chesney.
I had to get another visa. Oh Wow.
Just to get through that checkpoint.
I'll never forget like we got
to the checkpoint and they like,
we had the all give them my stuff
and it could be a, it could be,
it was like get out and the dude was like
get out the army guy with his gun and
then I get out and I come
around the car and could be,
he was like get your camera brother.
Right. And then he was like,
they want to take a picture with
you with the camera. I was like,
God what the Hell Y'all about to do? Yeah,
I call it like a bad case of diarrhea
while I was over there cause I eat nothing
but meat. I was trying to do
Quito, I was over there and listen,
the toilets are just a hole in the
ground. Do you have to squat? Yeah,
you got to squat and pull
the string or whatever.
So I remember like we was
driving from his village at the,
that was like my last night there and
I called like I was always destroyed.
I was like,
we got two hours and we like stopped a
couple of times to eat and pray and all
that stuff. Like, you know,
and I remember like I was suffering and
could be like filming me with his phone,
laughing, looking at his
brother, look at his brother,
he's about to shoot and said,
and I remember getting back to the place
where I was standing Dagestan oh my
God, I probably lost like eight
pounds. It was crazy, man.
It was a crazy experience, man. It
was a crazy experience in Dagestan.
That's life changing. It changed my
life. How long were you there for?
Nine days. Wow. It changed
my life. Really? Yeah,
because when you, in this type of
industry, everybody materialistic.
We all want nice things. We want to live
in Nice places, on to drive nice cars.
I do.
Most people do want to live nice and
comfortable and I saw just how happy these
people was just living their
lives. Like, went to his village,
I went to his mountain village and I was
in a city and I saw these people were
just happy and maybe on,
on the outside they was happy and maybe
they was dealing with other things that
we don't know about.
But I saw familiness brotherhood and I,
I had a little bit of
respect for their culture.
Like obviously with Islam
and things like that,
there's so many different
sex that makes it bad.
Just like with Christianity and,
and people in the Catholic community
and the priest and everything.
And that's my experience with the
Islamic community being around cubby.
So that's the only thing
that I can go off of.
And obviously everybody see Muhammad
Ali and he praises and things like that.
But um, I had a new found respect, uh,
for just the simpleness
of, of that, like a beep.
I thought honestly it could be,
it was going to retire after he fought
Connor cause I talked to him a little bit
about that and cause he don't want much.
What did he say after
the color fat? No, no,
before the kind of fight before
he was, he was just like,
what do you think about, uh, me retiring
after the Conor fight? I was like, man,
you do what you want to do. I can't
tell you. He was like, I mean,
I'm gonna have money. What
else do I need to do? Right.
Because he obviously knew that
was going to be the biggest,
the biggest fight ever. So at the IFC
make for that fight, I don't know.
Well remember they took his check, right?
But obviously he got a lot money for
that. They gave him a con counter.
I think Conner had $4 million
check and it could be,
had a $2 million check and then obviously
they had the paper viewpoints. Right.
So I was like, damn, where my money
yet? I promoted the things match.
You should've definitely unpaid for that.
Listen, you know what's funny is that,
uh, somebody asked me a long, it was like,
if you got anything out of this whole
thing, what would you want? I'd be like,
I camera, let's go get a new camera so
I could shoot some movies or something.
Right. That's literally
the low expectations I had
out of making the series.
Right. Especially when there was a
documentary. I was just like, man,
maybe I'll make this documentary,
put it on Netflix or Amazon for free
about fighters and now looking back on it,
the stuff that I have
captured on him, hard drives,
I can sell a documentary for
millions of dollars. I think I got
Mazin footage I got,
I got the whole Connor
thing that I got like that.
That tape is like 20 minutes.
Nobody's ever seen it. I have it.
No one's really seen the whole thing.
Like I got Connor when he
first ran down the tunnel like,
cause I seen him from a distance.
I wonder if the UFC would be against you
putting that out or pro you put nothing
out because well I put it
out on my channel a snippet
and then at the end of it
going to happen. I was like watch the
full episode on embedded right. I,
I gave them their just do and then they
literally told me like all we'll give
you credit. I never got credit. Uh,
I was just hoping they put shout out the
anatomy of a fighter for helping us get
this footage. I never got that.
They should have either way.
You're getting it now. Yeah.
So here we are man. And Yeah,
you know like going from the first day
I walked into that gym and saying C'mon
Ooze my toe filming him for two years
and all the way to the title when I used
to post videos of Camarillo Guzman on
the channel and he'd get 4,000 views and
people like, why are
you posting this bomb?
I'm thinking to myself
like these fans are crazy.
He can't pay attention to that. Those
are just, it's hard John. Even the fans,
it's hard. It's trolled. It's a
tiny amount of lose. It's crazy.
Cause I love the MMA fans.
I'm close to the line that the last time
you were here we were talking about the
comments. You can't read it. You
can't, it'll drive you fucking crazy.
Cause the people that want to
comment and want to fuck with you.
It's the smallest number,
the loudest, the most vocal.
And they have the shittiest lives. No
one with a good life wants to do that.
No one,
no one is happy and healthy wants to
fuck with you and say it's crazy when you
put your time and effort into
something, like say for example,
I flew to Phoenix,
film shine and film Bader and
then you spend all these hours,
10 hours editing something and then you
put it on and then somebody like this.
That dude sucks. It's like damn man,
you appreciating what I'm doing.
Are you just trolling
you talking tomorrow?
I mean you're reading
the thoughts of morons.
You're reading the thoughts of
limited minds. That's all it is.
It's really that simple. Yeah, it's nuts.
Anybody who thought the come
out loose mine was a bum.
I knew whose mom was a murderer years
ago. I just saw him fight years ago.
I want, nobody wants to fight
that. I know I used to put your,
I used to love taking
snippets of your podcast,
your voice cause you just that narration
voice and putting it with stuff and
like you can be like, oh that was a
universe pulling us together. But no,
I just was like this goes with this.
Like I like when you
and Shab are together.
I love that because y'all able to bounce
ideas cause obviously his experience
with the fight game and then your
experience with the fight game,
y'all able to bounce a
debate and things like that.
And I'm like that's a good mix.
Like a lot of people go in on a episode
I did at a weigh ins with Connor and
Khabib and it was like you and shop
talking and that's just the narration shot
of how I do film because that's what I
love about document sports documentaries
is narration and that's how I get
it. I get so many people that like,
oh I want to, I'm trying to do the
same thing you're doing. And I'm like,
don't try to be anatomy of a
fighter. Right? Like, if I,
if I'm filming one fighter, this a
thousand other fighters, not just,
I don't want to just do UFC, I want
to do better. I want to do one,
I want to do boxing. That's why I was,
I was trying to say earlier, my goal,
I would love to do it anatomy or
Deontay log. I bet you could do it.
I bet you I tried to get, I had
Andy Ruiz and, and they did.
So what happened was micro, she
reached out to me and was like, Hey,
do you want to do Andy Ruiz? I was
like, I'm thinking John Ruiz, right?
So I'm like junior, junior, or
senior, right. And he was like, no,
the guy that replaced big baby Miller
and that's one of my good friends,
big baby Miller. And uh, he was like,
yeah, man, he's fighting Joshua now.
He got a good chance. I had posted on my
Instagram like a text message from him.
He was like, man, it'd be
a good opportunity because
I think he can really beat,
uh, Joshua. And he did.
And I missed out c those are the moments
like the Connor Dolly thing is key
moments in film like this
viral nation that you need to,
that's why I film everybody. I
found these guys. It's not popular.
Things like that because these guys may
be the champions one day and I want to
be like I was there at the
beginning and that's the,
that's the thrill you get out of it,
if anything. Right? Yeah, and I've,
I filmed the pseudos, I filmed the
ooze. Mine's a film that could be,
I've been in locker rooms
with the title winners.
I've been in there when invoking loss.
Well you were telling me
some great footage that you
got that you wouldn't have
gotten that store wouldn't have
got out about pseudo about.
So Hutto coming back from
the Olympic gold medal,
winning the Olympics in wrestling and
then fucking living in the gym to,
to win the golden.
That's crazy. Crazy. I never knew that.
That's the ecstasy I get
out of filming these guys.
Like you hear these little stories and
I was like, you never talk about that.
Right? Like, you know, he's running with
the whole heel of the gold metal thing.
Well, he's doing some
weird shit now. He's like,
he's calling himself the king
of cringe. What is that about?
Well, because people was calling them
cringy like just, you know how they, they,
they rake on Luke Rockhold
the triple c now, now
triple c, he'd run away.
He liked the Mexican Colby. Covington.
Well, you better be careful what he is.
Is he a beast though? His
mind is just unstoppable.
The fact that Marlon fucked him up like
that in that first round and was chewing
his legs out. I mean, I did not think,
and it looked like he
was going to get k out.
It looked like he couldn't
close the distance.
Marlin looked calm and comfortable and
super professional and then a flip switch
switch, flipped. And then the second
round came around. And so who knows,
just walk at him down and
closing the distance. Then.
Then he gets him in the clinch
and lands knees. I'm like,
this is like a fucking movie.
That's Eric Albertson and Santina and
the Franco and all those guys over there.
Uh, that fight ready has something
to do with those guys. You know,
when he lost it, I did not
know when he lost the DJ.
So who though was lost? He went on
a whole world tour to find himself.
He went to Thailand. He went to Brazil.
He was trained in everywhere
after he lost it the first time.
And that's those little
stories right there.
Like he felt like as he needed to
get better as a martial artist,
he said, I mean with DJ at
the time, it's arguable now.
Who's the best? It's like him or
John Right now he's at one FC.
It's a totally different
ballgame. But with DJ was,
was the most complete package
we'd ever seen the most. The,
the guy who you couldn't hit, you
could hit you, he could wrestle you,
he could submit you, he
could strike with you.
He had incredible footwork and
speed. I mean, DJ was just perfect.
And that night he just found that
opening just fucked him out with these,
the body. I mean, DJ man,
there was moments in DJ's career where
I remember watching him and calling his
fights. I'm like, God
damn this dude special.
It's like something about what he's doing.
He's so far ahead of
everybody in the division
so far. I'm about to go up to Seattle or
Kirkland [inaudible] sample for one FC.
Concentrate on mad. He man, human's
a bad mother fucker. Oh my God.
He's got such a deep knowledge
and understanding of the sport.
You ever see him fight? No.
Mad Him stopped, uh, Pat
Miletich back in that day.
He saw pat, he, he, what did he, who
did he submit? Kenny Johnson. He,
I forget who it was in one of
those. Um, they, they used to have,
they had a professional submission,
grappling pay per view event.
At one point in time. Frank shamrock
submitted Dan Henderson and um,
Matt Hume was a fucking straight
up killer. I mean, he was a really,
really good world-class mixed
martial artist back when nobody was,
he had excellent Moitai excellent
submissions. He was good at everything.
How has, how has this
Seattle MMAC well, I mean,
there's been great guys to come from it.
Like Josh Barnett and of course
mighty mouse being the biggest one.
It's not as big as say like Miami,
like where you're at in
south Florida. That's,
that's the biggest problem I live
in south Florida. That was that,
I mean Blackzilians and American top
team on one spot and then a plethora of
world-class Jujitsu
around that area. I mean,
and then also world-class boxing
obviously mean that's where I'm, I mean,
I'm, what the fuck is his name? Sugary
linens trainer. Muhammad Ali's trainer.
I'm the old guy. Custom model.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The older guy who said to us, no,
no, no. You're blowing it son.
Fuck is his name. The old
Italian guy. Fuck this.
I remember saying, I can't
believe I can't remember his name.
This is embarrassing. Um,
sugarrae Leonard's boxing trainer.
Angelo. Angelo. Dundee. Yeah.
Angelo Dundee. Yeah. Blowing it kid.
When he comes out and stops Tommy Hearns
the next round. That's crazy. That was,
that was a, that was Miami. Denver said,
I'm not going to be in la long
like la or not. You're a gypsy man.
So my whole thing is,
honestly, Joe, I need to,
I want to settle somewhere though.
What do you want? Settle Danvers.
This is that. This is
all was going to ask you.
So these are the three cities I'm
thinking about to settle for maybe a few
years, four years back. The
San Diego, Denver, and Seattle.
Which one should I choose? I would say
San Diego or Denver. I love Seattle.
But that went or that rainy
season can suck my deck.
You can't do it.
It'll drive you crazy when it rains for
seven weeks in a row and you look out
the window, you're like, I
gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Isn't not enough online dating.
Be sitting in there
swiping left, right? Nah,
it's just vitamin D man. It just say
it really is not good for your health.
San Diego, San Diego. Love it.
Well, I love Sandy. I live in a,
a nice apartment complex now and the
good thing about it is I can transfer,
they have a relocation program. Like
if you want to transfer 30 miles away,
that you can do it for free. So I can
choose those cities. Oh. So like I
can just transfer it to them cities.
I'm thinking like, man, I got to get
out of downtown La. Man, that's crazy.
Girls rose, it's not a real downtown.
Sounded like downtown New York.
It's like the walking dead
around. Yes. Ah Bro. Listen,
I live there all the time. It's gross.
I went in there the other day and I was
going to get like some quest bars and I
seen like this dude in the aisle like
and he, and he was like, what's up man?
And he had like a basket full of
stuff and then I look at him again.
He just like open enough stuff eating
it. Like you go to another aisle,
somebody just roaming with a cart and
these is all homeless people just putting
stuff in carts and this didn't
get kicked out by security.
And then you see them in check out
and you're like, this is crazy.
It's every day downtown is insane.
It's infested with homeless people.
You can't fix it. Like the only way to
fix it is bad. You'd have to take them,
arrest them, put them in a plane and
fly them somewhere and drop them off.
But that's what I heard they
doing. I heard they did that to la,
like dropping people off in the
late. Didn't we go over this?
We went up and someone got
sent to like Indiana. What?
We looked this up and in fact
they'd been doing that forever.
Sending people all around the country.
This whole flight paths of what
they did with homeless people.
They just send homeless people and
let someone else deal with it. Shit.
They need to drop them off in Denver.
It's hurting our Denver getting bad too.
Of course it's getting
bad with that weed money.
The weed money and now mushroom money
cause now Denver decriminalized mushrooms.
Prostitution next. Whoo.
Probably cheaper than dating djs.
Hey man, La boys tough. I don't, I don't,
I'll probably just spend a lot
of money on first dates. Yeah,
I'm sure you want to repress realistic
cause it sucks to be a man and dating
because you got to impress. Well, if
I remember the precedents, listen,
when before I started making money and
having money dating was fun cause you was
broke and you can do smoothie dates and
Starbucks dates and then you know he was
going to spend five, six bucks. I
have a conversation. I'm 37 yeah,
that's you're too close
to 40 to be doing that.
I know you can't do that no more.
You gotta you gotta take chicks to palm
springs for the weekend or things like
that. Well they want to knock me
and stuff now though. Sure. Yeah.
Like this guy could take them to
a nice dinner. Yeah, I'm nice.
I don't fault any woman that wants a
man that has his shit together. Yeah.
Because for so long I didn't and now I do.
Now I want to have some fun of
course. Yeah. For, forget that.
I ain't trying to complain no more.
But as far as like cities of the Vibe,
I love the vibe of San Diego
and I loved the vibe of Denver.
I love those cities. Yeah. I'm,
I'm leaning towards back to San Diego
because it's still close to like,
I just drove the Irvine
other day. I was like,
that was a simple drive as long
as you do it earlier. Yeah.
He tried to do that shit at
four o'clock in the afternoon.
You want to shoot yourself? You
want to, there's the Irvine Improv.
I workout all the time, dude.
When I have a seven o'clock show,
I leave here at fucking noon
and whatnot. Not playing games.
I leave here at noon. I get there
early. I check in, I have dinner.
I don't fuck around with
that 4:00 PM traffic. It's
insane. It took me six hours
to get down there once.
When you went to shop show, when he
had his special, how early do no known.
Known Damn. Got a hotel just
to put my shit in. Checked in,
checked out. I didn't even stay there.
My daughter had an event the next
day that I had to go to for school,
so I drove back. I said, yeah,
I drove that back that night after the
show, after the second show, I say easy.
That's an easy drop though. I remember
some bad. Yeah. Especially late,
late at night. Yeah. You get a couple
of red bulls and you have your phone.
Yeah, I got to La quick once a
from when I lived in San Diego,
I used my boys truck. I met this girl
online in the middle of the night.
It does draw a girl online in
the middle of that, listen,
I know if I ever was going to
end up on a Joe Rogan podcast,
I thought it was going to be for me
writing a book about an online dating,
real professions of an online
data. I swear I do that. My Ex,
you don't need a book, but
just do a video about it.
Do documentaries about how crazy that
I used to film girls and interview them
and everything about dating. Like what
sucks about dating and things like that.
I'm lying. Dating is only
existed for like, like at its
raw form 20 years. Right.
Ross forum was 20 years ago.
That was like AOL. That was you
as a Weirdo then though. Oh Wow.
Everybody listen
if you, if you do Tinder or bumble in La,
you see and celebrities and everything
on it. I'm ready. Yes. Chicks like Ollie,
successful chicks surgeon for
love. Wow, that's scary. Justin,
why is it scary? Because you don't
know who you really meet him. Like
for a woman, imagine being a
woman and you're gay. I was,
it was sucked to be a woman
and trying to be weird.
A successful celebrity
woman trying to meet dudes.
You want to hear this
story and this is crazy.
So I met this famous online female
trainer, beautiful here in La.
She's very pop lang. I'll say her name.
I met her on match.com and
I got her Instagram and she,
we, you know, we exchanged our Instagrams
or whatever. So I re I looked at it,
looked at her, are her Instagram
and she was doing like, you know,
content but own her phone,
like in our living room doing like
squat jumps and things like that.
And I reached out to her like we set
up a date, we going to go hike him,
run and do everything. And I was like,
listen, I looked at your, your, your,
your Instagram page and your content.
I would love to be able to help you
out and give you better content.
She lost it. I don't need your
help. I don't need your help.
You look like you need to
help yourself. Like I'm like,
I'm just telling you that I could help.
I'm like, why? Like I am a filmmaker.
I could help you do some content.
Like she, she took it the wrong way.
Like I probably tried to take advantage
of her millions of followers and things
like that. I was just
like, boy, I was like, man,
I'm going to be single forever.
But I think sometimes that's also,
there's a very limited communicating
with on in a text. Yep.
It's any ticket the wrong way. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. You got to kind of meet people.
Like if you, but I bet if you met her
and you said, hey, you know, you're,
you are, you're beautiful.
You got a gray body.
These videos are great and everything,
but I think I could make them even better.
She still wouldn't take
it the wrong way. Oh,
she was like in her 40 forties probably
still get set, but she was a female.
You know those Alpha females that you can,
some girls have been
fucked over so many times.
They think everyone's gonna fuck them
over. It's like a dog's been beaten.
You ever pick up a dog
from the pound? Oh yeah.
I've had dogs in the past and you're
like, Hey, I love dogs. Come on,
I'm not going to beat you.
This is nuts. So yeah,
I would probably think San Diego
would be to move. Or Denver.
I like both of them. Man, I'm going
to go wrong and you can't go wrong.
Well you can't go wrong MMA wise.
Like San Diego has a alliance.
You know San Diego has a ton of
Great Jujitsu. Shout out to my man,
Boogie at 10th planet and
then it's close to here. Yeah,
it's real close to here. But then Denver's
the fucking Shamberg on a lot of gym.
Denver also has really good vibe.
I liked the people in Denver a lot.
I liked the people at San
Diego too. I would it look,
I'd flip a coin if I had
to move out and no kids.
So I would just click on San
Diego. That's it. Everybody,
that's how I'm going to do.
I would be happy either one,
they said you can't go wrong. And
they're both a good size city.
You know what I'm saying?
Like not too crazy. Yeah.
Like San Diego is a great size. Cities
kind of going out got like, I'm not,
I don't do clubs. You know,
I'll go to a bar here and there.
Cutting your online dating right.
Gets in the way. Well, I don't know.
I think in the early days I was
in the clubs every day. Yeah.
That's a waste of time. It's, yeah. A
lot of years I wasted just partying,
not trying to get my shit together.
So I feel like now when
it's different, when you,
you find a passionate man and
you get obsessed with it. Yeah.
And I'm obsessed with this anatomy of
a fighter thing. Like I have a, um,
a post in my phone that I was
going to show you where it was. Uh,
it was like August 22nd,
2017 and I had four 54 subscribers and
I was like 46 till my first hundred.
And I was like, listen, it's not a lot,
but I appreciate all the supporters, uh,
that I have.
So this is going to be one of the biggest
MMA documentary channels in the world.
And that was August 22nd, 2017
when I first started the channel,
I couldn't even name it
anatomy of a fighter yet you
have to wait till you get a
hundred subscribers.
So like looking back on that
journey in a sacrifice that I,
I've made to like I went from south
Florida to Vegas, Vegas to Florida,
Florida to here and now here we are.
How many subscribers you have now?
How many dog got Jimmy a I
think to 238,000. Beautiful.
I have a little thing in the
back from when we had a thought,
100,000 subscribers. We got a
little award. Yeah, I got one too.
I was like silver creator, 1000
a hundred thousand subscribers.
I was my only goal
with anatomy of fighter. I have a,
my, my friends have youtube channels.
Uh, and I seen what they was
doing and that was a goal,
like the silver creator award. If
you get 100,000. And I was like,
maybe I get it in two or three
years. That's what I thought like,
and I can just do this on
the side. And then once,
once I started getting
some traction, I was like,
let me ease back on weddings and that
I'm leaving guaranteed income and
comfortability that put my time and
effort into this because now I'm like,
I can't, I got 200,000 people
following me. I can't go back now.
I've got to continue to
build this. Well, it's to be
giant man. You really
talented and it's really shit.
And what I like about this podcast,
what I was hoping this podcast was
going to be is exactly what it was.
I love to hear people's
stories. I love to hear.
That's one of the reasons why I like
documentaries because I think we can all
relate to moments in our lives where
we're lost or we just didn't have it or it
wasn't we, you know,
it was a halt, wasn't,
it wasn't where we wanted it to be and
trying to figure out how the fuck do I
get it together? How the fuck do I
make it happen? It's the real, yeah.
It's like Instagram is fake. Like
you make it look whatever you want,
but documentaries won't lie. Exactly.
And that's the reason why
I love doing that, that,
that form of content because
it's just like everybody, listen,
one thing I've learned about the whole
series is that everybody's not gonna like
a certain fighter. One fighter
is not gonna get a lot of views,
a some people,
and not even going to care about that
fighter because that's just the way
momentum in popularity is. But I,
that's what I love it the most.
Like somebody asked me the other day
because I had posted a picture on my
Instagram of the NBA draft.
It was one player sitting by herself while
they was interviewing Zion Williamson
, all the media. And you know
how it is immediately in the UFC,
everybody got their name or this guy
was sitting by herself and nobody was
trying to talk to them. And I said,
Yo, if you ever in this position,
use this as motivation. And I
think like C'mon Guzman posted,
like I've been there where nobody
wants to pay attention to you.
So somebody comment and was like,
would you rather film Khabib or
a regional LFA guy? I was like,
the regional LFA Guy,
I take pleasure in the connecting with
people just like me. I'm not popular.
It was that picture right there. Like
nobody's paying attention to them.
And that's how I just clicked.
No thanks to the pop up ad.
That's essentially what they're
saying about him. No thing. So that's,
that's how I feel even in the media
circuit with what I do is with
everything. Yeah. I mean I've
been there as a comedian,
I've been there in the early
days of podcasting. You
know, it's, it's how it is.
It's just life is a journey.
And what I love about your story is that
people can relate to someone struggling
and then figuring it out and then
it gives them hope. Like, okay,
I'm struggling now,
but if I just make the right moves and
put the right amount of effort and focus
and dedication to something, I can
make something happen. Everybody can.
I've really believed that and I love
that. It's one of my favorite things.
I'm a, I'm a success
junkie. I love watching
other people's success.
I'm a big fan of other
[inaudible] well yeah,
it's helping people. Yeah. Listen, um,
I've been in locker rooms when they
lose and I'm in there when they,
they win and it's the same for me. I
feel bad for the other opponent. Like I,
people always ask me,
do you get any type of excitement out
of filming guys when or not really?
I'm just telling the story. You have
to be like that. Like Colby Covington,
C'mon ooze mine.
I would love to be neutral and film both
of them and do a story on Colby in a
story on Uzma. Like people
always get mad was like,
why don't you post about this fight? I'm
like, I'm finding this myself. I'm not,
I can't, first of all, again,
stop rules, fucking comments.
They'll change perception. So I've,
I've met people that have gotten
mad reading comments, they go crazy.
They think the world's out
to get them. I'm like, Hey,
you got like a hundred people that are
talking shit to you and then you've got a
thousand million or whatever the fuck
it is. They love, they love you. Don't,
don't do this man, don't do that.
But I, but I do wish I, I get,
I can't wait till I get to a point where
I can have the resources to go film a
lot more content because
I love doing this.
Like I would love to go to when you
had colonial Roundtree on and I had
commented on it on a comment on Youtube,
like I would love to do anatomy of
Kahlil and Thailand. I'll hook it up.
I would love to just go there to Thailand.
I couldn't, you know, collegial. Nah,
I never met him. He's amazing.
Just go out when I send you on the edge
in no damn buildings like he was doing.
He crazy for that. He's crazy. But the,
the transformation that guy's made as a
fighter from when he went to Thailand,
he's back there now. He's in Bangkok.
He's a beast man. That Eric Anders fight.
I was like, Holy Shit. And Aaron, he's
a tough dude. He's as tough as that.
He did. That was one thing Kahleel
said he never even winced. I mean,
he is eating leg kick after leg kick
from a guy who kicks as hard as anybody
I've ever seen. That's
crazy. Khalila is so fast.
When I was watching him throw those
kicks, I was like, well, who is this guy?
He was weird. How did
you turn into this guy?
Like you see as earlier fights and you
see this, he beat go guns go, wasn't it?
He not go concentrating loss, right?
Yeah. He lost the Johnny Johnny Walker.
Johnny when he went and
reinvented itself again,
Johnny caught him with an
elbow in the clinch man.
He caught him with one of these of these
elbows in the clinch and he kao them
and you know, he would just said, okay,
I have to really learn Moitai and
so fucking I'm going to Thailand.
I know he went to Thailand and I
followed his Instagram journey, you know,
watching all his training footage and
that and he just fell in love with
Thailand. And then he
came back and I'm like,
this is motherfuckers fight like a
tonight looking like Saget from street
fighter but like a jacked
muscular 205 tie too crazy.
That's crazy man. The nicest guy.
Yeah, he couldn't get a nicer guy.
It's nuts to to see that transformation.
Like to see him go from like
this guy that was chubby
and then this world class fighter.
Well does that too. But the
difference between him in,
well it's hard to say, right because the
goal, Khan Saki fight was real quick.
He just cracked him in the left
hand and Khalila is very fast.
And then see him getting Kao by
Johnny Walker. But then to see,
I've saw his other fights.
I've seen many fights of his,
but see that the transformation, I'm like,
what the fuck the kicks man it was the
kicks that he put it all together and he
was fighting tie style.
It's like he was one more of the most
representative of Moitai I'd ever seen in
MMA cause he, he just, he just absorbed
was, was better that
the Thai style kickboxer
Dutch. There's no better man. The
thing is like, look at Ramon Dekkers.
Ramon Dekkers went over there and he
fucked everybody up in Thailand and he was
their size. It's the athlete,
but it's also how they incorporate
it in, you know, this look,
there's some great tie fighters.
Like I'm a w who the fuck is,
I forgot how to say his name. That
just a doom bages knocked him out. Um,
big time tie fighter, uh,
be had like 200 pro Thai fights.
He had so many do make
caught him with a in glory,
caught them on the right
hand. The clinch k owed him.
It's like everybody sty and
doom bays. More of a kickboxer.
It's everybody. It's, it's the athlete,
but everybody style has merits.
Like there's merits to just being that
wrestler who ground in pounds and doesn't
throw many kicks.
There's merits to being that Jujitsu
guy that doesn't care that if they get
taken down, it's just like,
who are you though? Are you,
are you Damien Maia on the ground?
You know? I mean if you're Damian,
my on the ground, there's
merits to that style.
Damien Maia has strangled a whole lot of
world-class killers that never even got
a punch off on him.
Uzma I got out of that
wizard, they broke up,
they fucked it in Maya Naba. Lev is the
guy he knocked out in his last fight.
Doom, Doom Bay's a beast. Well, set
your doom base and interesting guy man,
because he reinvented himself. He
was more of like a runner, not or,
I want to say a runner,
but more of a mover and he would
win on points and he would,
but then he'd just let the last few
fights. It was a couple fights ago,
two or three fights ago.
He fought a, I forget,
I forget how to say the fuck his name
said. I don't remember how to say that.
His name. Thai guys
have those crazy names.
I uh, but I want to do this.
I'm Finna do some stuff with uh,
glory to glory is amazing. Gory does
not get the respect that it deserves.
No, I'm a giant fan. I
watch all the glory. That's,
that's what fascinates me
about what I can do. Yeah.
Cause people just think it's UFC. No.
And Anatomy of a fighters. Everybody,
anything. It's all of that. So what you're
doing babe, if cops are on that dude,
he's my favorite. Cedric Doom
Bay. Poof. Yeah. Sox's man.
He flat lines. Everybody he's
gone to. There it is. Sit.
Sit Song peanuts. That's it.
Tongue ties sits on penal.
Say that real quick. Great.
Don't Chas sing songs? Sing them.
Go but go back to as a, is that
so that guy that he fought,
Tom Chai, Tom Chai had like,
I mean hundreds of fights.
I don't know how many
fucking fights yet. Total.
It was more than a hundred type
fights and then a shit ton.
Look 136 wins
175 fucking fights take 39 losses
if I've won 136 times. Yeah,
he fought 175 times. That is insane.
So I mean he's got that Todd style. We're
doing base more of a kickboxer style.
A lot of times people say,
well they prefer the Thai style because
the elbows and the clinch and the knees,
but doing bay flatline,
Tim, it's the athlete.
It's the way they incorporate their style
competing against the other style and
there's merits to kickboxing.
I prefer the Thai style
because I think there's,
there's a real benefit to being really
good at the clench. Yeah. To be in,
especially when it comes to MMA. Real
good at the clench the knees to the body,
the elbows in the clinch and kickboxing
does not allow elbows or knees to the
body.
But we've seen world-class kickboxers
that have come on like like cro cop.
You've had tremendous success in MMA
going from kickboxing and to MMA.
I always wonder where
like somebody like race,
EFL Nim would do is prime in MMA like,
well, look at Mark Hunton and mark.
Hans had a tremendous run and Mark Hunt.
He fought race fri. Yes he did.
Yes, he fought race at fault. Um,
I mean when you go back to
Mark Hunt, Mark Hunt really,
I mean when he won the k one Grand Prix
was probably when he's in his prime as
an athlete and then he fought
a lot of fights and prides.
By the time we got him in the UFC, I
mean Mark's in his forties now, right?
I mean, I think his mark still is he
retiring? It just lost his last fight,
right? Who We lose to Willis? Um, yes.
Yes. He lost a wills. Yeah, I think
so. I think he's, he's retired though.
I don't know, but he's probably close.
You know, I mean, he's had a long, long,
well, not when I'm, when I was living
in flood. Like my home gym is hard.
Knock street 65. That's where I started.
That's Henry hooves chip. Right.
I love that guy. That's like my big
brother, man. Love like a trainer.
He needs a platform to tell his life
story because it's crazy. Henry Rufus,
he just got back from Thailand. He
went over there, he told me, he's like,
I just got away from the game for a
couple of weeks and then I came back
refreshed. Um, cause you know he,
he's a beast.
Like I wouldn't want to like get caught
in the alley with Henry Hoof Dog.
He's a big fellow too. Yeah, he told
us me don't kick your damn knee out.
Like that's just how it is. I didn't
pissed him off a couple times.
He didn't kick me through the cage. Why?
I just complaining like
complaining like, Hey man,
these people didn't pay me enough and
he like quit complaining like fell back.
I was like, Damn. I was like
holding on to the case. I'm like,
hoof is a bad man man. You don't
want to get on his bad side.
He's a great trainer. He isn't.
He a great guy and I'm happy.
AFS, listen star in his journey.
I've seen so many people say, Oh,
who've is a great coast,
but he just can't coach a champion
and just to see him grind in finally.
But he has champions. He has ong and
one fc two double champion. Yeah.
Michael Chandler done one
to build a couple of times.
How do you say on this
first name? I'm honest.
I learned in songs how you
pronounce it. I don't know.
That's why I call him and
he's a beast man. He's a B.
People are sleeping on one fighters and
I think when you see guys like Eddie
Alvarez go over there and get KOD and
you see a lot of fighters go over there
and have real mighty mouse
had a real hard fight. He did.
That wasn't an easy fight. I love Chautry
too. It's a d. I love Traci as well,
but it's a different world
where you're not cutting weight.
It's a different world. You know those
advantages that you have of being big,
they don't exist anymore. You're now
fighting someone who's your size.
I think it's better. I'm a gypsy. Hey,
I would love to go live and seeing the
pool and just in a just film one fc guy,
maybe cha treat Chautry if you
listen and if he hears this,
maybe you'd have you come down
and I talked to, I talked to uh,
the executive producer of content.
They want me to do some
stuff for them though it is,
it's changing the landscape of MMA because
it is literally larger than the UFC
worldwide because of Asia. All the
millions of views. 1 million. Oh my God.
Millions and millions. Every.
Imagine if I got the Asian market
on anatomy of fight over them,
subscribing it all my God. And then we'll,
the good thing is you wouldn't be
able to read the contents comments.
The comments would be all
in Asian. You'd be like,
I don't know what Tom was saying.
Great. Thank you. Thank you.
Don't fucking read them man. It's
tough man. It's the hell it is. It's,
it draws you in. Yeah. You'll be
healthier and happier. You get it.
They're like, I had got
addicted for a minute.
Like the Khabib effect and
kind of our effect is real.
And you post the video and you get
100,000 views within the four hours you'd
like, it's going to be like this all
the time. Then you post, you know,
shout out to my God, Desmond Green, uh,
a video of him and this insightful and
it's talking about some stuff and he'd
get 5,000 views and it's kind of
like that. It's like a high, right.
And it's like I got away from it though.
That's the reason why I was like,
you know what? I started thinking
about a lot of stuff in the past month.
I was like, man, I just
need to move somewhere.
Live a normal life and film and I can,
I can go fly somewhere, come back home,
live in Denver, live in San Diego,
and just be away from popularity and
materialism. And, and that's the thing.
It's like, I just want to stick to
building this however long it takes.
And like I said, if I look back
on your channel on it, I see.
I can't imagine where this could be in
six years, I imagine, where it could be.
Yeah, no. And then it can be gigantic.
Especially when you think about the fact
that you have so many different arts
and different disciplines to
study more. Thai kickboxing,
Dutch kickboxing, uh,
boxing, Jujitsu, Jujitsu.
I mean there's so much you can study in
so much you can watch and so much you
can learn, but you're going
to train yourself. Kamala,
who's my told me I should go over to
a undisputed and uh, or unbreakable,
unbreakable and glazer. Why not? And just
throw some hands. We'll just do some,
oh no, you're fine. You've built for it.
[inaudible] get that long dusty shirts
man. Make you look good. Pants drunk.
Well you obviously work out. Yeah.
Yeah, I'll work out every day. Yeah,
every day. But I kind of, you
know what I, I I did, I did a,
I read a whole thing on runners
high yesterday cause I was like,
I want to get back into
running for endorphins. Yay.
Yay. How much do you weigh?
Two 30. Yeah. That's
the thing about running. Like,
I really think that a lot of
people overdo it when they're,
whether larger people in the beginning,
and I think you really should
make sure you, you get someone
Mala Day is fine a couple
miles a day. Yeah, sure.
But make sure you don't run on concrete,
man. Hell Nah. Treadmill. Yeah.
Try not to swim or do, I
haven't since I've been in La,
but in Florida I swim every
single day, every day for now.
We use one of those
life runner treadmills.
Those ones you self-propel
[inaudible] we have one all yeah,
they have them at the institute too.
Yeah. What is it called? Not Rife
runner. I made the wrong word.
They have them at the institute?
Yeah. Yeah. Air Assault.
It's like an air assault. The air
assault bike. The same company.
They make that treadmill. It's the shit,
it's literally 13 something like
13% harder than regular running.
So it makes you better at regular running.
That was called salt air on her
assault air runner. Yup. Okay. Yeah.
I want to get back into
run into, yeah, I'll, I'll,
I'll show it to you when we get done
here. It's really good because you can,
you, it's self propelled. You're,
you're pushing it rather than
keep cause with a treadmill,
all you're doing is like lifting
your leg up and putting it down.
You're not really propelling yourself
forward. You know what I'm saying?
Like the belts moving. But this,
you have to make the belt move and
so when you're making the belt move,
you're actually pushing with your
legs and strengthens your legs up.
I prefer it.
I'd be,
I'd be afraid to do anything at my age
where I'd be seeing these basketball
players just tear tyranny, Achilles
by just stepping. I'm thinking like,
yeah man, that's tough. Yeah.
I wouldn't want to get kicked in my
left knee right now, but I have like I,
I study things that I film
right? And I'll just be like,
specially like Henry Hoof,
I'll look at all this leg kicks when
they teach and leg kicks. I'm like,
if I ever get in a street fight,
I just need somebody to properly
teach me how to kick in that leg.
I'm disabling whoever in my face.
That's the first thing I want
to do is kick you in your leg.
I'll punch in your face. I'm
athletic enough to beat your ass.
But I'm just saying like the kid, it's
the wrestling that's gonna get you,
cause most fights end up on the
ground. So you got to know what,
what to do when you tussling with them.
When you go to Ted's planets tonight,
just ask them to show you some
shit. Yeah, I'm gonna get any Bravo
orange choke. What a choke with
long arms. A great for chokes, pat,
great for chokes and
Darcy's and Armin chokes.
Cause let's look at John. John my height.
Sure. Like I've been around China.
I just think like you see John Jones
on TV and then you see them in person.
You're he alone.
Mother fucker. As long as he will
fuck you up the best at using it.
No one's better at using
distance ever than John. He did.
Did you ever see the video? He uh,
do you know Dr Bow hightower is yes.
Like when he let John Kick him?
He did? Yeah, he just left. He,
I guess he like why he just let them kick
them in and John kicked him in his leg
and he just buckled. I was just like,
oh my wouldn't let him kick him.
I think he had uh, reached the
number of subscribers on youtube.
So for the to be crippled.
Yeah, true. Crazy.
John is a beast. I met John a few times.
I haven't done that anatomy at
John Jones yet. Um, oh yeah.
Watch this. It's crazy. He's putting
his weight on to John is crazy.
Oh boy. He deal to another
doctor too. Oh my God.
It's crippling doctors and
he bit didn't even hit him.
Nah,
but you know how weak that leg can be
if you don't train that and strengthen,
how do you even strengthen
that part of your leg?
Get used to getting kicked there. You're,
you develop all these weird veins too.
It's real strange. Here's he, Kevin
Randleman his leg after he fought Pedro,
him around him. Him with the hair he had.
Didn't he have his hair
blonde or something?
Sometimes some fights. He had crazy
blonde hair, but he had big legs.
I was jacked Super Jack,
but he fought Pedro [inaudible] and Pedro
his own fucked his legs up so badly.
These giant like veins, like weird,
like broken veins all over his
leg. Randy couture had them too.
Also from patriotism. I like Randy all
the years I've seen people kick legs.
Randy Prob, I mean Pedro,
his are probably kicked harder
than anybody I've ever seen.
I remember I watched him at Beverly Hills
Jujitsu in the 1990s he was kicking a
heavy bag and I was just
like, what in the fuck?
His leg kicks were preposterous just
cause it would just bend that fucking bag
in half and you just think about
what it would do to your leg.
Pedro fucked a lot of people up.
Pedro Hippo was a fucking
beast back in the day.
I've seen a lot of people get fucked
up in the gym. I just don't release it.
Yeah, I got a lot of footage that I
can't ever embarrass people. Right.
And that's the thing,
like I appreciate all the fighters
that have let me document,
they lost because they trusted me with
the intimate parts of their lives.
Like I'm getting invited
around these guys, kids,
they wives like you just don't do that.
So that's the respect level they've
given me to where they trust me that I'm
doing well with the story. So I
appreciate all to take care of them. Yeah,
you have to hone it. Listen,
when I first used to come into the gym
with hoof them at the Black Zillions,
I remember who it was like, who the
fuck is you? Who are you? Right?
Like what are you doing here?
Right? Like you have to gain that.
Like I get so many fans,
like fans be like, Hey,
do you think I could be with you at
a fight week? And I'm thinking like,
Nah man,
you have to build your way to distrust
this is these managers have to trust you.
Like the gyms have to trust you. These
coaches have to trust you. You know,
some people you real picky about
what you film and you know,
maybe it's a one week after the fight,
they know a lot of people watching
the channel now we can't release.
That's the how they was with so Hutto
when, so Hudl followed a Marlin,
I had released a snippet of the episode
I was going to release and it was like
they was on the opposite sides of the
cage at the gym and it was like fight.
And then he came out exactly the way
he was going to come out with Marlin,
but I wasn't paying attention. It was
slow motion. He was just coming out. So,
so Hutto freaking out fight week. He
like, Bro, did you post this shit?
I'm like, no. He was like, man,
you got to take that down because that's
exactly what I'm doing with Marlin.
And I was like, aw man. Was he
doing that was so unusual. You know,
like as soon as the fight started, he
was Finna come out in a certain stance.
He was gonna come out in a certain
stance, like a look, you know,
his little karate style. And
then he was gonna actually do,
I don't know what it was, but he
was freaking out and I was just like
that.
The thing about Marlin is
Marlin is a giant one 35 yeah,
I mean Marlin is so big. I don't
know how much weight he cuts,
but I know the California won't let them
fight one 35 again because California
has that room where you can't hydrate
more than, I think it's 10% or so.
You can't blow back up.
You can't blow it back up.
So he did blow back up in a fight in
California, said no more, one 35 few cars.
So it's very obvious that he's cutting a
tremendous amount of weight. He's huge.
He's huge. So it like a comic
book character. Yeah, he is.
So I think that he cut way too much weight
and I think that that contributes to
his demise in the second round
because he couldn't take Henry out.
Henry was a lot done with the
needs, the knees. I was like,
it's 10 days in a row. What
was ridiculous? And he didn't.
He let him clinch with him
like that in a way that you,
you don't do unless you're tired. And
it just, I think he compromises himself.
I think there's two things going on. One,
I think Henry has a force
of will that very few,
few human beings can ever
possibly understand. I mean,
Henry has a self belief and,
and just a stainless steel will,
that motherfucker just puts it on you.
And I think Marlin outclass
him in that first round,
but I don't think it's sustainable.
I don't think you can keep that pace
with that dehydration level and with what
he's doing to his body to make
135 pounds. I think he cripples.
So where does the division go now? Since
Henry goes out, here's the problem.
If he goes to one 45 right?
If marlin goes to one 45 then he doesn't
maintain the same advantages that he
has in cutting all that weight. Then
he's the size of these guys, Leo.
Okay, so he goes to one 40 foot.
Just think about guys like Calvin
cater that can flatten Ryan, you know,
crack flatline you and he's tall and long
and that shit is not going to work on
him the way it works on those
135 pound guys. It's a different,
it's a different world.
You got Josie Aldo,
you know you got Max Holloway
who's walking around at
one 80 and get down to one
45 and that's his teammate though.
What's as a beat. As a beat. Yeah.
I'm like my God man. It's a beat
as a mother fucker's a shot.
That's a Shalane monk. Woo. He's amazing.
They go make a movie Jack Stan Guy.
They're gonna make a movie of him.
Yeah, he got a crazy store. Yeah.
Like monk type
stuff. Send them off as a kid
type thing. Yeah, they listen.
Xa beat up. I've never
seen it likes a beat.
He's filming him and training him. His
English getting better too. It is good.
That's a good thing for him. Like I
think he is. He's the next, well man,
there's so many stars.
Bruin and Dagestan. It's,
there's so many of them
over there. And sure, well,
if they have that mentality
and they're that tough,
I mean there's just that that breeds
more people like that. You know,
killers breed killers. You look at
like Jim's like Aka, right? You know,
you've got Cain Velasquez, Daniel
Cormier, age, you know, go down the line.
You know Luke Rockhold, John
Fitch and Josh Koscheck.
How many fucking killers have come
out of that gym? You got to see a,
they could be even and play basketball,
uh, in Dagestan when I was over there.
It's like one of my most popular videos
where they train, they play basketball,
full game hours of basketball and then
train for two hours and they no dribbling
but doesn't compete. You have fucked up
knees. What do you mean by no dribbling?
It's called Dagestan basketball. Just
hold onto it like rugby, basketball.
Come on, look at this. Look at,
what the fuck am I looking at?
It's the craziest thing
is hold onto it. No,
they trying to wrestle.
They throwing you down.
Like people are getting choked out.
Like it's the craziest thing ever.
This is the most ridiculous. I
could be so sorry. In basketball.
JV. Jamie loves. This is the
look, look, JV. This is crazy.
White Russia basketball audit. Look,
look, it could be what happens.
It gets intense too. Oh my God. I play
with them once. Why don't they dribble?
I have no clue. Let's look at his
dad. Look at his dad. Look at his dad.
He and he intents to yelling at him.
They probably play with a medicine
ball now they playing with a red.
You said a medicine ball heavy
as hell. That is so ridiculous.
Watching people run around and play
basketball. Look at him dribbling. Look,
that is hilarious. Look, it could
be look, be scored. Look, look.
He looked at me. He pointed it to me.
He pointed to me like you had have
you traveled? This is not reasonable.
And they play for hours. That's,
and then they're like, oh,
it's coming to train. It's time to
train now. So that's their warm up. Yup.
That's the gym. Could be trains in
Riley. That's it. That right there.
That's crazy. The fact, look at
these guy. Look, the fact that they,
they play a different from
version of basketball.
Did you just get killed?
What happened there? It man,
this look trip at the end of this could
be even going like choke somebody out
like it's really, yeah, it's crazy man.
They they not and they run on
the mats with their shoes on.
These motherfuckers are going
to get staff look, look, look,
look where it could be.
What is happening here.
This is so ridiculous.
Running back playing rugby.
It's like rugby, basketball.
That's what I called it.
But they call it a different thing in
Dagestan and I found that they call it,
it's something, it's like
Australian rules football. Right.
And like Dagestan goes bad literally.
And I'll play, I'll play with them.
And my knee was swelled for two days in
Dagestan because they tackled you. Oh,
they was killing me.
[inaudible] look after,
after I was trying to dribble
or scoring and everything,
but when I kept getting my knee
started hurting, it could be,
it was like brother,
you too big to be sorry.
I was like, Hey, I can't move in. Is Wrong
with you? Like you twisted your knee.
Yeah. They all, they was all
arguing about picking me up.
Cause I remember that when I dumped on
Khabib, I sent you that, that, that,
that image of me Duncan on can be
like, he's trying to guard me. Yes.
They really wanted to pick me up.
Then it was like, oh, we getting him.
So I'm thinking he is going to be easy.
I'm gonna just hold the ball up and jump
board. They was taking my knees out.
They was taking it easy on each
other until they saw the black dude.
When they saw the black dude
play, they was like, oh,
we really knocked out the guy who
actually had the potential to play
professionally. Yeah. And they, and
they go on cray. Look, look at this.
This is hilarious. This serious.
They take you serious to skip ball.
That's fun. Look at the balls. Look
at it. Every time it hits the ground,
it's got no bounce. Well
he, he dimed him though.
Well it looks like the floors are regular
boss stadiums. Look how happy days,
looking at the debt like that. It is
running with the fucking ball like this.
It's little and this is slow motion. So
you see, look, push you out of bounds.
They do all that. They did
that to me a couple times,
but they run on that fucking beat. Let's
look at this. Look at this. Watch this.
Look at this. Here it is right
here. Watch this. Look, look,
look. Could be bang. Stopping.
So he's wrestling with this dude.
Why is he doing that?
Because there's the hold them down like
and now the wrestling wrestling look
could be may stopping and they're
doing it on the mat. Look, look, look,
babies are mad man. Oh my God, he's
taking his back. He's choking him out.
He never easy in tab. That is crazy. So
they wrestle all their playing points.
Yes they will tackle you down to there's
no rules. No rules. That is hilarious.
Look, the guy tapped already
and now he's got him.
Was I already tapped? Ah Man, he's
bringing back memories. But wait a minute.
So you look man,
people trying to get cookie Boffo why
is his teammates cause cause you free up
another opponent so you can play. But
that it could be, look at the beach.
He thought his jockey Jay right there.
He got even thought the right there.
Oh Man. That is crazy. Seeing the
MMA fighters playing basketball,
that's the worst thing.
This is not basketball and
this is something different.
I mean, when you're not ever dribbling.
Did you see the video
of Francis [inaudible]?
He paid an Amish design Williamson
and then he was out there shooting
basketballs. ESPN just did it, bro.
For instance, the worst athlete.
He's not athlete, Bro.
I'm sorry if you can't,
if you six foot five and can't
dunk a basketball being well,
don't you remember when
Mike Tyson was in his prime?
I remember you saying that basketball
with the, with the overall,
what's his, he's got dedication to one
thing. One thing. Yeah, that's the thing.
I mean, oh my God. Well, I'll tell
you the little, little, little look.
He's laughing though.
That's probably the first time he ever
tried to do that and he will punch you a
pinkie and your soul will come out
your body. It's so fucking hard.
When he hit Alister, there's another
kickboxer made it big in MMA right now,
stir over him. But when he, but Alister
was already a real Allister's, very,
very well rounded. He's not just a
kickboxer, but k one grand Prix champion.
You've got to call him a kickboxer. But
when he hit Alister with that left hook,
I was like, Jesus Christ. He
said he saw it the other day.
They did a free fight.
They did a free fight on a a UFC channel
and I just watched it over and over and
over and I was like, Danny was the
follow through punch. Yeah. Oh Jeez.
That's the scariest, the scariest
moment I ever, I wouldn't say scariest,
but the most intimidating
moment I ever have.
I was filming Francis eating a
banana and he didn't like it.
He didn't like you following him. I was
in the elevator with him and ooze mine.
We was in Pittsburgh when we did USC.
Pittsburgh when Rocco
fought David Branch back,
Dan and Francis came
to support come morrow.
So they going to do Jujitsu in a little
workout room and Francis was like
talking to ooze. My opening and a
banana and [inaudible] and I'm like,
he put the bit in his mouth. He
stopped eating it and I'm filming.
He looked a he like slapped the camera
away. That was my boy though. Friends,
my boy. But that was before
I really, no, no, I'm eating.
You've maybe just tying in with
bananas in a mouth. They might not like
the banana in the tailpipe.
That was funny. For instance,
intimidating man. Oh, he's terrifying.
When he clipped Cain Velasquez,
here it is. There's that uppercut
uppercut left hook, like a shovel hook.
Look at this. Boom. Before right
before that, his swagger, how he was,
he had the confidence bouncing his
shoulders like he was ready to,
he believed he was the greatest
in the world and then his sleep,
a fight changed his fucking trajectory,
man. It really did change his life. Huh?
That's a really interesting fight
because Steve pay was a real champion.
You know, it's crazy.
I was in the room next to Francis
in Boston and he didn't go.
He never went to sleep and I had my door
open like so my room was right next to
Francis and I had my door
open cause I was like,
if fighters come by I'm gonna just catch
them with a camera with your door open.
I kept in the middle of night
editing because that's, you know,
doing fight week, you know how
embedded releases they series.
I'm filming all of these fighters and
then I'm going back up to my room and I'm
editing but I'm already
editing in my head.
That's how I'm able to get stuff out.
You clean what program you had anyway,
premiere now premier just doing it.
Just slapping it up as quick as you can.
But see my method when I film is I'm
already knowing what I'm gonna use. Okay,
so you making your cuts. I know the
opening shot, I know everything.
Are you writing all this stuff
down? I'll keep it in my head.
Just keep it and people will be like, how
can you edit and release it that fast?
It's like it's already done
before I go to my room.
I just have to go up there and put
it together. Music, everything.
I'm able to just, I don't
know how I'm able to do it.
It's just something natural.
I've been doing four hours.
See you have a deep passion.
Yeah I have a deep and I've
developed the skill set to is easy.
You know they always say oh well you
put in 10,000 hours and something,
you become an expert.
I feel like I put in my 10,000 hours
doing all types of different types of
shoots to to survive.
And now this is my arena.
This is my big stage. Right.
But I remember that week France has
never went to sleep. I be like Bro,
go to sleep. What are you
doing with your door open
trying to catch you. And
then he would come in,
sit on a bed and look
at what I was editing.
Cause obviously I was filming him
as well. And it was just funny,
like just doze type of memories. That's
like what time was it that he wouldn't,
he never went to sleep all night. Well,
you know you get there Monday, Tuesdays,
right? Saturday.
So it may be Wednesday and you still
up at three in the morning cause you
fighting late. He know because
think about it, think about it.
The last fight is what time? 10 o'clock.
Yeah. Nine o'clock. Well La time.
Boston Times midnight. Yeah.
Midnight. Yeah. So he up,
cause he can't go to sleep early because
he got a fight and that's one thing I
discovered about the fight game.
Like Dan, that does make sense.
You know you fighting at 11:00 PM
yeah. You want to keep yourself,
you gotta say so he just walking around
the hallways, big ass Francis in Boston.
It's crazy. It's like looking back
on that stuff and it's like, man,
I've captured a lot of stuff
already. What's crazy is with him,
you watch him and then his next fight
against Derek Lewis and neither one of
them through anything.
Derek had a fucked up back.
He really pillar like the Polly
Polly and Artem fight. They,
nobody wants to do anything. I thought
it was terrible. Oh my God, I watched it.
The fact that Artem beat
him in a boxing match.
It shouldn't have been even no
contest. But Paulie's never had power.
He's never been him hands is brittle,
you know what I mean? Hands is brittle,
but he's also, it's never been
a guy that could just stop,
keep you all kind of really beat the
hell out of him. I firmly believe it now.
You think so? Yeah. I don't, I
don't like after watching that.
Well also after watching
Paulie's examination of
that fight afterwards you're
like, well you thought you lost lost. You
made me thought you wanted a decision.
You thought you got to shit decision.
Like you didn't do anything. Nah. Connors,
what'd you think? Kind of gone do whatever
he wants. Probably do a lot of coke.
You know what's crazy? Before?
I was kidding. Before I ever,
he's going to have some fun man. I
think if you find a fight that's fun.
He's got $100 million in the bank.
If he finds a fight, that's fun,
he's going to do it.
But the problem with him is eight mean
they wanted him to do cowboy and there
was some talk about him doing a cowboy
fight but he wanted it to be a main event
and the UFC wants main events to
all be big time championship fight,
anything kind of do as big
time. That's what I said.
But they think that somehow or another
having no championship title online,
I would love to spend a day in the
life with Dana White. Well Justin Gait,
I don't think you'd let you do that. You
don't think so? Conflict of interest.
Yeah cause he's got,
they've got their own thing that the UFC
and best sucks cause I really wanna do
the anatomy or Dana white just hanging
out with them for a day. Who knows?
But around with the help
embedded and maybe would help the
Tuesday night contender series.
It would help pump that up. Yeah.
Air Guy Barris has said
the perfect thing. He said,
why would the UFC be worried about you?
You like eliminate stand and
they Coca-Cola. Well I think
that way but some people don't.
Some people don't want to
help other things get going,
but I'm promoting them [inaudible] if
you stop promoting them and just really
concentrate on a belter and the channels
gigantic now because you did so much
UFC contest. True. That's
how people look at things.
Well, you know, my first
idea was to tell the UFC,
let me just film all the fighters. Y'All
not going to promote this fight week.
So embedded is 10 other fighters.
Let it anatomy on fire to get them.
Give me a credential and let me just
filming them all week. So I'm around film.
These fighters that y'all never gonna
post. What did they say about that?
Not Interested. Never. Nah, I didn't
get a, not interested, but I don't know.
It's, it's weird because I,
I much love to the UFC because they
gave me a lot of access and I love every
single person over there. Like Dean
Klein and Heidi Dean, all those people,
I love them. They treat me like a
knowing cousin. They're great people.
I'm an annoying cousin when I'm
at five and that's the thing.
I haven't been to a lot of fight weeks,
but it seems like people think
I go to every fight weekend.
It's like I only go to ones that
I can afford or they make sense.
Like if I had the funds, I'd be
at every fight. Week filming.
Are you going to be in Vegas
for the Jon Jones Taco sauce?
Yeah, because I'm nominated for award
against you. Oh really? For what?
The World MMA awards. Best
MMA programming. I what?
What am world MMA awards that Cari
MMA show. Yep. Now you're on it.
So I know that's so weird that it's so,
well I told you confessionalism and online
data was done with the way I thought
I was going to end up on here.
Well I hope you win cause I want a
bunch of those. [inaudible] it's me.
You embed it. Dana Weiss con Tuesday.
Can Siri continue to
series and then a MMA hour?
I hope you win against me. How
about that? Had be a, had to be.
I smoke weed. If I did I'd
be like, I'm done. I'm done.
I understand you. Your
reluctance to smoke weed.
I smoked weed maybe five,
six times until I was 30 years
old, like a handful of times ever.
Like a couple times in
high school, you know,
a couple times afterwards at
parties. I get it. I mean I get it.
The whole personality thing. I
when I, when I was 30 years old,
that's when I started smoking,
like really started smoking
weed and I don't think,
I don't think anybody should do anything.
If they have an obsessive personality
and they're worried about getting locked
into it, I mean I don't think
you should drink, I don't think,
but if you can handle it,
a little bit of weed I think opens up
these doorways of creativity and I think
that it's very valuable. Boy told
me, cowboy telling me about mushroom,
mushrooms, mushrooms as well, I think.
I think a psychedelic drugs with
their marijuana or mushrooms there.
They're tools and the way I've always
described it as like you could take a tool
and you could build a
house with it, right?
You could take a hammer and you could
build a beautiful deck or you could just
hit yourself in the Dick if you're
fucking crazy. Sure you could.
You could abuse a tool, but
it doesn't mean the tools bad.
It means the application's bad and you
don't give a hammer to a two year old,
right? You don't give a little kid,
we'd tell them to smoke it every day.
But I think for a grown adult it's good
to participate in something that gives
you an altered state of consciousness
because it allows you to look at yourself
in a fresh way.
And for someone who's always like trying
to be self assessing and objective and
always trying to analyze who you are
and your thinking and your behavior,
I think something like marijuana is very
important because it allows you to see
yourself in this way that
maybe you don't ordinarily do,
allows you to drop your blinders and get
a glimpse of how other people see you,
which is very hard to do. It's very hard
for especially people that you know,
you put up your barriers, your
defenses, you have an ego.
It's hard for you to look at yourself
to find the things that you're doing
wrong. So if you can't find the
things that you're doing wrong,
it's very difficult to grow. So a lot of
people call that paranoia, that effect,
that marijuana produces in a small
pot. I don't like smoking pot, man.
It makes me paranoid. That paranoia I
think is awareness. And I think you,
you close those doors of awareness in
order to get through your life. But the,
the subconscious is always
aware of these things.
The subconscious is always aware of these
things that are fucking with you. Uh,
marijuana just finds all the problems
and just turns the lights on.
So if I moved to Denver, I'll
probably end up smoking weed.
Everybody smoked at all.
If you do it just to,
what about an edible little edibles kit?
Careful can't hurt like
a cookie and fuck you up.
I heard a cookie will destroy you.
I got some quick shot. Rashad Evans,
that's like my big brother. He always
told me about the toad. Oh, five minutes.
Oxy dimethyltryptamine yeah. Yeah.
That's that. That'll fuck you up to. Oh,
he's done that. And I said, yeah,
you can go into another dimension
or you literally can, I might,
I might be the president of the United
States and other dimension. Who knows?
There's no United States and that
other dimension. There's no states,
there's no people. There's souls
go into like a well of souls.
That's crazy. Disembodied entities
and told, I remember when I kept it,
what the Hell is you talking about?
The toad that told nobody
gets it from a toad though.
They're really five minutes.
Oxy done metal trip to me and again from
usually from laboratories synthesize
with a bunch of precursors. But
the, um, the, the, the other one,
n n dimethyltryptamine is the one we
see the visuals. It's all really, yeah.
How long had lessons? 15 minutes.
Unless you eat it. If you eat it,
what if you did it in the float tank?
You could do that and you'd have
to do it quick. Like you'd have to,
have you seen the full tank here? Yeah.
Remember? Oh, that's right there. Yeah.
Um, have you done it yet? Nope.
You got to you gotta I seen how
extension they was online. How expensive.
I've seen some, yeah, like the by one
by one. But you could always this a,
the float lab, they have a,
it's in Westwood.
They have a place in Venice and then
there's a giant place that opened up in
Pasadena that uses all the float labs.
Was the name of that place again? Yes.
Just float. Just that place has that.
That is the biggest float,
uh, establishment on earth.
You do it for how long?
Well, last night I did two hours.
Damn. I like two hours. Yeah.
I like to just get in there and find,
find out what the fuck I was when I was
with Cheeto Vera Verda that day when his
teammates did it for like an
hour and he was just like,
I didn't, I ain't know where I was. I
sleep in a dream or even just crazy.
You're disembodied, you know,
Charlemagne trauma and the gun,
he a was on last week and we were talking
about it because he's doing this whole
mental wellness retreat sorta center.
He's like establishing these mental
wellness centers. He is. Yes he is.
Cause you know Charlemagne is his new
book or shook one is all about his mental
health. His anxiety is
issues with anxiety and um,
you know,
anything that allows you to relax and
just to center yourself can help you with
anxiety and, and you know, that's one
of the things that he said about the,
the tank was that he's never felt
stillness like that. That's crazy. Yeah.
Cause you're not, you're not feeling
your body. You know, your body is just,
you can do it. You try it out. He had a
crazy life. Yeah. He's had a crazy life.
Yeah. He had a crazy life.
And then also like I said to him about
he's the last Samurai in terms of radio.
Radio is a dying industry. He's the last
guy I think to get famous off of radio.
Yeah, that's it.
Charlemagne, the God is like,
I saw a little bit of it and I
remember he said that he was literally,
he got fired at 31 he was 31
no job with a two year old.
And that's what people like when stuff
is inspiring because people beat,
I wasn't unemployed,
I was like 29 when I was lost and then I
was turning 30 and that's when I got my
shit together.
So to hear Charlemagne and God say I
was 31 I had a kid and I was no job.
Like I think so many people in life are
so obsessed with getting somewhere fast
and the understand that takes time.
And just to see somebody like that be
open enough to say like I was at a low
moment in my life, like at my age now.
I used to think when I was 25 37
with young or old, old as fuck,
you're young as hell. You're not old at
37 no more. Yeah, you never been there.
It's just, we always talk if you're
a healthy 37 when we were kids,
our parents were attendant at 37
they're working 12 hours a day.
We felt they felt 50 probably
felt a little, it felt 50 that's,
I mean thank God to the Internet. I mean,
cause if it wasn't for the Internet,
I wouldn't be able to put
up these amazing videos.
I would have to go work
for one of these companies.
It's also the Internet allows you to get
all this information and allows you to
stay healthy. You get up, you get a better
understanding about diet, nutrition,
mental health, relaxation, how
important meditation is. You know,
and I think one of the other things that
Charlemagne did that's very important
as he talked openly about anxiety
and he's a famous cool guy.
He's like a famous guy known for
his opinions, known for being Brash,
for him to say, Hey, I've struggled.
I've had real mental struggles and
mental health struggles. That's,
that's a very fragile
conversation in a black community.
Um, mental, mental health issues
and in anxiety and things like that.
People don't want to admit it, right.
Cause when we all but know
even tough it out. Yeah.
You want to feel brave
and not for me, man. I,
I felt hopeless and defeat many
times in my life. Sure. Me Too.
And Luckily for me, sometimes I say, damn,
I don't have kids. Luckily, you know,
I've been able to, to,
to figure it out on my own without
having a responsibility to take care of
somebody. Right. So I've been lucky in
that sense where I haven't, you know,
had a child, a son or daughter. And
I was like, and that's, it gives,
that gives me youth, it feels like
every day I wake up, I'm like,
I can do what I want to do because only
person I'm responsible for is me. Yeah.
And that gives me the freedom to be a
gypsy. I couldn't be a gypsy if I had it.
No, nothing like that. You have na
the life button. But you know what,
if you had a kid, you would just
alter that life and you would have,
you would take great comfort in the
fact that you love someone deeply like a
child. It's a, it's a crazy thing.
The love you have for children. Yes.
It's changes people lives. It
changes. Like I see how you are,
whose mind went up and he had his
daughter when he's carrying his daughter.
And that was crazy, man.
So hard for me not to cry so hard for
me not to cry when people win and they,
they, they start thanking
their mom or you know,
the parents hug them or it's like when
he was holding his daughter up, I'm like,
oh Jesus, here comes back.
That was crazy. Listen man.
W you know,
remember when he got in trouble for like
the 30% or people you're going in on
him cause he was like, I'm
30%. I was 30%. Yeah. Like I,
the thing that I can say about
being around these fighters,
I see all the injuries and everything and
then people don't understand what they
do in the fight.
Well how about the fact that it was
my to that fight with a broken foot?
I know I seen him crazy.
I seen that he had a broken foot when he
fought Tyron motherfucking Woodley and
he never stopped coming.
Never stopped moving forward.
You would never been able to guess by any
stretch of the imagination that he was
injured. Yeah, I did. I did. Cause I
filmed it all. You knew it. I knew it.
I just can't release it. You see
what I'm saying? I'm not going to,
now after the fight, I can
say, yeah, he was injured,
but I have that on so many fighters.
So who though? Everybody like, wow,
who those ankles. I know. How crazy
is that? That was Kudos angle.
The week of the fight was giant,
black and blue completely fucked up where
he couldn't walk and then he goes in
there and fucks up. Marla morale
could be Conor fight.
Didn't they say he had like a Conor and
something wrong with his foot too or it
could be had a problem with his weight
cut? I heard. Did he? I think so.
It was a bad way. So big. He
other, he's a mountain man.
What is his diet like?
It's clean from what I see, but he's
had problems making weight in the past,
but that was two oh nine think about
that. How long ago that was? Yeah,
UFC two oh nine yeah. That was the last
time he ever had a problem, but it's,
you know you had problems before
that though. I didn't know. Yeah,
I didn't even know. It could be at two
oh nine. Oh um, yeah I that was when, uh,
the first UFC event I ever went
to. Does he have a nutritionist
like in, in Dagestan? Does he have, I
don't know cooks for him. I don't know.
But you eat with them? Yeah, but that
was Robin. Now he's eating all meat,
meat and potatoes and I sat with everybody
and he does he train during Ramadan?
Yes he did. That was the whole Dagestan
chronicles. People couldn't believe it.
He trained, trained too. So he trained
trains during the day without eating,
without drinking water. Crazy man.
Why I'm talking about
really hard to like that.
That's the initial, oh
I want to turn. Yeah.
I want to turn that whole
series into a movie.
Understand kind of being able to
work out like fast workouts. Nah,
fucking no water. Like
training Jesus Christ,
implant that basketball lightly
with no water. No nothing.
That is so crazy. That's what I'm, that's
what I'm saying like that mentally,
that's what I'm saying.
That mental toughness like and then
when I seen the face off with him and
Dustin, cause Dustin, I would love to,
to document Dustin cause he's a good guy.
Um, I thought Dustin was huge when
you just see him with everybody else.
And then when he did the face I
would, could be, if I'm like damn,
could be taller than him.
Everything I'm thinking like, man,
he's gonna have to keep that
guy off him. It could be,
it was just such a good wrestler.
His said he's going to grab him,
put him on the ground mount. I'm like
that double dummy and smash them.
Now I'm out of fire so I can't say it,
but I kinda feel like that's how I
always call ooze amount of black could be
because as soon as he grabbed you
to fight over, that's how I feel.
As soon as he grabbed you,
it's over cause you're not going to
get away from him anymore. I'm like,
I'm latched to you. So,
but that Damien Maia fight,
that referee saved his,
I know I was in a blocker room like
cussing and never known. You know,
he would just,
we don't know what happened cause
the world can change if that referee,
whoever the fuck he is, I don't even
want to know his name. Last Maya fight.
He see how he took the back. That's
what he does. Yeah, against the linemen.
Good. That's what he does to
everybody, man. And that referee,
that referee separated them.
And I was sick and Matt,
Sarah went fucking crazy about it
and I was, I was with a tough one.
But still it's, you don't do
that. I said what you would,
what would have happened? He said,
I would have just held it there the
whole time. But you just never know.
Well if that's how he lost his first
fight, he lost the first five again.
Choked out. I know, you know, you know
this is something that people don't know.
So Uzma got one fight that he's lost.
Colby Covenant has one fight
that he's lost. That's what this,
I'm all about stories like the storyline.
So the only fight that Colby Covington
lost to was what? Leon Edwards?
Yes. He choked him out.
Right. Short notice fight.
They took in the UFC and he was injured
at something fucked up with ribs.
So he lost by via choke.
Who's my beat? Leanne?
The God that [inaudible] lost too
early on Colby covers him beat.
So BofA day losses are two people that
that's just a weird storyline. Yeah,
but that's MMA. Math. Yeah, I know,
but no and I, I'm not comparing them,
I'm just saying that the fact that they
both got one loss and eight supposedly
hate each other and is two
people they've beat it is crazy.
Ho fighters careers just changed.
They become a different person and
whoever they are like four years ago,
you really can't compare
them to whoever they are now.
The Colby Covington thing is interesting
because he really did beat the shit out
of Damien. Maya, you know, and you know,
he really did hot failed Los Angeles.
I don't know if Damien Mayan was three
rounds. I feel like it was a main event.
You might be right though. Three rounds.
Three rounds. Cause he was in Brazil.
This was five rounds. Yeah.
Yeah. But Don Dosantos one,
two rounds. Right. Three to two.
Did he think on score cards?
He took them down and everything. Yeah,
he did. Yeah. Now with tomorrow Kamara,
it was brutal. They level change
that Kemal do with that level,
like threatened to take
down. He will piece you up.
Cause Henry who's got his striking
crazy and is getting better. Yup.
Oh for sure. Well he did fantastic
against Woodley Woodley in real trouble.
From striking. Yeah. Well it looks good
in this comeback trails though too.
All the oily managed that he's
doing. He really got married,
dedicated Willie didn't want me to film
him the week of the fight by this game
and shit. Uh, Dean Thomas came
over to me and said, hey man,
I willy don't want you to film
him. It's another distraction.
If I get it, I get, I was mad. I was,
I was kind of, I wouldn't say mad.
I was butt hurt cause I like
willing, I'm like, come on man,
I've been filming you all week. And then
all of a sudden day before the fight,
hey, his head, he doesn't want anything
there, you know, just wants to see,
I mean he had so many distractions.
He released the fucking album with
Wiz Khalifa. You know, he was touring,
he was doing a rap videos,
slept masses. He's, yeah,
and he's doing this fucking TMZ,
Hollywood shit that he does.
He does a lot of shit.
But I like that he does a lot of shit
because he's recognizing that he's going
to have a time outside of fighting. You
gotta have you gotta have a post line?
He's got a real opportunity to make
something happen forever. I mean,
he's a smart guy. Inspirational guy.
Yeah, I lot, listen, I have none,
but listen, I love after the fight with,
you know willy mom, that was amazing.
I love, I like Willie, his
team, his mom, his, his,
his mom was talking to me and it was
more both tearing up cause like we were
talking about and we played it when,
I mean his mom just goes over and we're
braces Comoro and Kamara was crying and
who his mom was like, she, she
coming for you, baby coming for you.
You better be prepared for Mama Willie.
Look got tears in your eyes right now.
Yeah. That, listen, that's the
sport man. This sport is this, this,
this emotions and soul
in this sport. It's like,
it's not just the winning and losing.
It's like your life is on the line.
So imagine what I feel
when I'm documented.
You're right next to them because you
know, like say it like a journalist,
right? That got to work for a show.
They reporting, they interview
and guys, I'm in the gym with
these guys every day. Like I'm,
I'm literally in it sweating
in a gym with these guys.
Go on with them to eat, going to
stay tonight, sleeping on a couch.
Like I'm doing all of that stuff to
be next to these guys to tell them,
why are you doing that? Well, because
it's yours. Yeah, this is all your,
your doing this, you know,
working for some fucking company and we
got some asshole producer who's telling
you what to do. It wouldn't
be the same. You wouldn't,
you wouldn't [inaudible] I wouldn't
do it. Not only would you not do it,
you wouldn't be as motivated. You
wouldn't, but more importantly,
it wouldn't be the singular vision that
you get when you know that it's coming
from one person. When you know something's
coming from one person, you get this,
like you get a feeling like this
is, this is will Harris. He's there,
he's filming this, he's admitting
it. He's putting it together.
He's putting it out. Here's the video.
That's a beautiful thing about the
internet man really is. It's amazing.
It really is. It doesn't exist in any
other media. There's nothing like that.
There's nothing like that ever
in the history of the world.
If you wanted to put out
something like you've done,
you need a gang of people behind. You
needed a network, you needed a deduction,
companies, someone to choose
you, you need to someone.
There's probably four of the guys that
wanted to do what you're doing with five
of the guys, 10 a dozen.
Everybody wants it and they have to pick
you and then these other guys would be
trying to like fuck you up from
behind. And it happens. It happens.
And I, and that's what I listen.
I try to portray that message to
every single person that messaged me.
This is not easy. Like it's
a lot of sacrificing this,
you have to be willing to
put in years to do this.
I'm going on two years in
August 14th will be full,
two years of committed to an
anatomy of a vita and I'm, it's,
it's a baby stage to me like I could
because of what I know it can become.
You know, millions of subscribers are
firmly, firmly so to me, I'm like,
you know what? I'm not going to stop
no matter what. I'm not going to stop.
I want this to be the biggest thing ever.
I want a guy that's not even
in on the radar right now.
I want to discover on him and then he
become a heavyweight champion or world or
UFC champion or Bella torque champion.
And that's the thing that I get out of
it all is the fact that I can just create
what I want. Yes. With whoever you know.
You know I I thought about it
though there I was like, man,
I need to put more women on a channel
of women fighters and promote more women
because I feel like they
don't get promoted as well.
I want to get Amanda Nunez,
um, Ashley Yoder. I was supposed to go
with her and Dan Henderson and Temecula.
I wish I could've got them on.
But that's the type of like,
cause it's the freedom to do it.
Yes. They don't have to pay me. Yeah.
I just go do it and make it and put it
out there and hopefully somebody latches
on and say we want to be a part of
this, this movement and anatomy.
[inaudible] Valentino Schiff. Chenko
and her sister, they are some beasts.
She scares the shit out of me.
I just want to film her doing that little
dance shit. I know. It's crazy, right?
That fucking head kick on Jessica. I like
woo. I was supposed to go get her. Uh,
Eric Nixon, her coach. She was like,
Oh, come down to Vegas and get Jessica.
That was a tough
one. I liked a Jessica was, you know, she
took it well though. She took it well,
but she was a severely outclass.
That was a, a bad level.
It's levels, levels,
but I don't think there's a level
higher than Valentina there. There,
there's people on her level, but
there's no level higher that that's,
that was a, a little a debatable
match against Nunez. The second one,
right? Yes. The one that people say she
should have won very, very close fight,
but Nunez is a bigger girl.
New Nana's is a legit one 35 or she's
not going to make one 25, you know?
And when she knocked outside
bark, everybody was like,
what in the fuck she
follow that line. Cyborgs.
And she's Cha. Excuse me. She's chomping
at the bit to do it again. Listen.
She's like, set it up
again. I'll do it again.
What do you think if Cyborg
left the UFC, where do she go?
One FC maybe, but who's
what? Fighters is over there.
They'll get some fighters
for, they'll find some.
There's some Moitai champions that'll
fight her. She was at ask women,
I talked to sideboard. She wants that
fight bad. The Amanda Nunez Fire. Yes.
She wanted a bench or she does. It might
happen since it was Ryan rock 'em sock.
'Em Robot. It was rock 'em sock 'em
robots, but only one person was rocking.
That's what I'm saying
from her. Yeah. She was.
She was moving towards and Amanda was
just doing the perfect thing to deal with
that style. I thought it was
going to be a harder fight.
I thought if Amanda was going to beat
her, it's going to be by decision.
Oh really? I really did. I was shocked.
I didn't think she was gonna flatline or
we'd never even, Cyborg always gets up.
She felt during a barge in in
lion fight, who's, you know,
world class,
top of the food chain Moitai fighter and
she didn't have a single Moitai fight
and barge knocked her down
twice and Cyborg was chasing
her till the last second
that's called the bell and
she just seemed so durable.
I just never thought I would see our face
plant Amanda Nunez hits like she's got
bricks in her gloves just wow. She
just drops those fucking things.
Nicest person in the world. You
would never think she fought so nice.
And you know when when her and sidebar
were talking on that Shit, you know,
she seemed like cool and calm and
like just you wait and just you wait.
She just knows man, she hits when
she fucked up Ronda Rousey like that.
I was like, good Lord. That was
a fight where I remember the,
the run up to that fight.
That was one of the first fights that
when WME bought the UFC and they were
really promoting the shit
out of Ronda rousing.
Ronda was like walking around some big
mansion looking at the TV and they were
going to say, this is the big
comeback fight. And I was like,
you guys should be paying attention to
your first ever openly gay UFC champion
who happens to be a fucking murderer.
Happens to be a chick that Merck,
Misha Tate, happens to be a
chick that flatlines people.
She's probably one of the
hardest punchers in the women's,
in any women's combat
sport. I mean, fuck man,
she hits fucking hard music. You know,
you've got to go back to an wolves,
one punch Kao and boxing
to see a woman wolf beast.
But you got to go to that to
see a woman who hits that hard.
And Amanda loves to fight, man. You
see, she loves it. She fucking loves it.
She, she feeds off of it.
And when they were setting that fight
up and they weren't giving Amanda Nunez
any credit and they were promoting her
at all, I'm like, you guys are crazy.
This is a bad fight for Ronda. This
is a bad fight because first of all,
that chicks,
a Brazilian jujitsu black belt Ronald's
not gonna submit her and she's probably
not going to get a dominant position on
her and when they're standing up on the
feet,
this chick is going to throw bricks
and it's not a good place for Rhonda.
That was like, it looked bad.
Like why did she second stumbling how
she was stumbling? She's out. I'm on,
you know, there was a lot
wrong there. A lot wrong.
Their motivation was a lot wrong there
to go from the Holly Holm Kao to that to
that should've had a warmup
fight. Right, for sure.
What is the reason why
boxing has warm up fights?
What is the percentage do you give
Holly home and chance against Nunez?
Well, Holly Holmes are world
class fighter. You know,
you got to give her a chance, get anybody,
she survived against Germane Duran domain,
knocked her down and germaned
around me is a legit world champion.
More Times that the fight with the late,
the late after the twice she got she,
she got though hind taken and she would
have won. I think she won that fight.
I think she won anyway.
Anyway, she dropped her twice.
She dropped her with a straight left
and she dropped her with a question mark
kick. Um, I thought
you won that fight, but
man it was just fucking
murderer man. It's hard to,
it's hard to pick against the magic
of Holly shocked the world twice.
She could look, she couldn't, I like
her too. She's, she's an amazing person.
Hey she, she hates the cameras, does
she? She won't let me film her. Why?
She won't let nobody film her. Just
distractions. She just don't like,
she don't like it. And that's one of
the girls I would love to do. Like,
you know, cause this is like
fun for me. So I'm like, Oh,
I would love to just
get this person on it.
Let the world get to
know this fighter. Right.
Like I get it from their perspective
though, cause it is a distraction.
It's another thing, another
factor to consider in.
Some people don't mind it like something.
I Bet Henry Udo probably likes it.
Yeah. In a way.
Some some I've gotten away from going
to fight week cause it's Kinda the same
thing. I've done it a lot.
So I like to just go away before a fight
and just document this stuff and then
release it during the fight week. What
is it like at a bad motherfucker ranch?
Donald Cowboys place? I haven't been
there yet. I've only been a Jackson.
Oh okay. Listen, I got to go
there for like a week there.
Just be with him and Schilling and
that's the place to go cause they're all
doing mushrooms and fucking jumping
jetski fresh eggs and stuff like that.
I would love to do that.
Cowboy is a, is cowboy.
Don't want them people like if you
see his face you think he's mean like
sometimes. But he's the coolest dude I
ever seen. Nice man. He's so nice. Like
that's crazy. Like when him and
when him and Mike Perry fall,
I had access to my period at fight week
and I reached out to cowboys team and
said I want to be neutral on this and
film both of Y'all that week in cowboy.
I said yeah, no problem.
So he let me hang with him.
I was with Perry after the
fight. They met, they talked,
I had that little famous moment where
they met and you know, cowboy was like,
you lit the fire in me and repair.
He was like, what? He was like,
you talking all that shit lit the
fire in me that Instagram videos,
like I'm coming for you. All that
stuff. So that's probably one of the,
if people asked me what
my favorite moment is,
is probably the Mike Perry
week because of just,
I had both of them and then I had the
raw emotion of Mike Periatt that he lost
in a locker room. Like where he, he
looked at the, he looked at the sky,
I was like, Damn God, you can
let me out the first round.
He like, Damn. It was embarrassing.
But it was a funny guy, man. He is.
He is a just start. He can do
anything. I feel like, I mean he,
he's gonna get better and
fighting. He can be in movies.
Well he's gotten better since the
move to Jackson's. He really has.
He's got more embedded. Went back
where? To a fusion XL in Florida.
He went back to his original team after
the cowboy fight. Interesting. Yeah.
And wonder why? I don't
know. I don't know. Cool.
But he's not a Jackson's anymore.
He's at a Fusionex thing.
I'm not aware of fusion.
I don't know if they have good
trainers or anything like that.
That's what Jack or a
train. Oh, okay. Yeah.
I liked what they were doing
for him know that Jackson's,
I like how they were giving him a more
measured Lester man calculate. Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. Frank the tank, they give
them a more calculated approach,
making them fight more intelligently,
more, more of a game plan.
Cause he's always going to be wild and
he's always going to have that power that
Paul failed to fight. Yeah,
that was wild. That was why.
But if I wanted to see that
fight a Felder, first of all,
Felder is a different way class,
but it felt it didn't throw that
spinning back fist and bounce it off his
forehead and snap his arm in half. You
know, they should run that back. Huh?
Um, well I don't think Felder
should be fighting one 70, you know,
because I don't think Perry has a
chance in hell and making one 55 no,
that Felder can till versus Perry
is a good one. That's a great, but,
and they hate each other. I liked
that, especially after till coming off,
getting knocked out by mom's
Vidar, two losses in a row.
So that's a great fight for two
losses in a row. But the big one,
the big one was a Mazda dog
cause Monzo dog flatlined them.
That was a d I thought
that was disrespectful. Um,
uh, the way the, the, they
had set it up where um,
the bookies had set it up where Tyron
Woodley was the underdog. I was like,
you guys are out or your fall,
you're in Dallas. I mean, you're out.
You're out of your fucking mind. I don't
know what hype you're buying into them.
We've never seen this guy on the ground.
We've never seen this guy with a guy
like Woodley and like Woodley hits hard,
tasty, hard. He's so fast and wrestling
wise, I mean it's not even close.
I thought that was,
I'm like, yeah, he beat
cowboy. Yeah, he looked great. Yeah,
he beat Wonderboy. But you know,
I mean it was a fight where he clipped
and Wonderboy boy was one really good
shot. You know, he, he hit him with one
really good shot and a good five rounds,
one column, a high train. Uh,
but I feel like promotions,
they did it with Pico, now
he got two straight losses.
Well you get excited about a guy because
the guy has some something special and
sometimes those guys that have
something special, they never,
like Uriah hall never really became
what everybody thought he was going to
become. We saw Uriah Hall and the
ultimate fighter. We're like, Holy Shit,
this is the next Anderson Silva. Like,
look at this guys. We'll kick in.
People in the head. Yeah, he
is built like a Greek God.
He moves like a fucking gazelle. He just
had this perfect style. Like Holy Shit,
look at this guy. But never
quite became who we thought.
And then the Paula Kosta Phi, you
seem to getting beaten down by Kosta.
He was fucking him up though. At
first with this shit at jabs. Yeah,
the Jabs Kosta can take it. I was
just like him versus yellow or marrow.
Good googly Mooglie. Is that
a crazy fight that's here.
That's going to be in California and,
Huh? Yeah. Woo. With Nate and Pedis.
That's the bottle about battle of
the best bodies ever goes to. Yes.
He inspired me. How you look
like that still at 40 something.
He's got the freak genetics man. He talked
about it on the podcast. He was like,
go look Cuba. Everybody looked like that.
He was saying that everybody looked
like that. It's just amazing.
Genetics and then Costa. Well,
it's also like when you think
about what UL has gone through,
that Cuban wrestling program,
man, they, they, they,
they just call everyone
who's not an elite five star.
Super a plus athlete. You ain't making it.
He was telling me that the people
that are the best, they eat more,
they get better food and they eat more
and they sleep in better places and they
set it up. Who you're training with,
all these other people
that want what you have.
So you're around them all the
time. If you see that podcast,
it's amazing cause deli joy was really
has to translate later with DOL.
Did he speak some English?
Yeah, he speaks a little,
but you know he needs help and Joey would
help them. You know, I never met him.
Yo Man, I haven't met him
yet. He's a great guy.
He's so super friendly and he's man,
he does shit to people inside the AUC.
You think he going to get
any of that money? Oh,
the 27 million from
the supplement company.
He for people don't know
what we're talking about.
He won a lawsuit against the supplement
company just like we were talking about
before with Sean O'Malley. Um,
they gave him tainted supplements
and he won $27 million.
It's a big company. See we, we
thought that it was a smaller company.
They would just go under. But this is
a big fucking company and you know,
their company makes $100 million a
year and they, they, they owe him 27.
Can you settle out of a settle?
Like the judgment was 27 million,
but could they be like, oh we gave
you 10 that's a good question.
I don't know how that works. If they do,
you probably could take that and assume
for the other 17 cause you have it.
Yeah, you gave me 10 I think
they're supposed to pay
27 million. I just don't. I
think they have to go bank.
He Shit never fight again. Well maybe
wants to though. He wants to be the champ.
You know he's got a legit shot.
I think he beat with a criminal.
I think he won that second point.
I think you won. I think he won.
What about Rockhold going a
light heavyweight? I Dunno man.
The way he smashed rock holding
that fight. I was like, good Lord.
And he kissed him. Well Brock. Yeah,
he kissed it after he flat light and
Rocco was talking about kinds of shit.
But Rockhold said he was like
hitting someone's made out of steel.
You said he was so fucking
hard lit. Rocko told me that.
I've never felt a human
like that in my life.
That's super five-star elite
athlete. That's what that is.
That is is elite as you get when that
guy goes into the cage and you see him
move around and it's like, Jeez,
all you got neck, no neck. You go,
how the fuck is he 185 pounds,
dude, I weigh 200 pounds.
How the fuck is your Elvin Marrow?
185 pounds. That's crazy. Sane,
insane. I seen this a
side by side with him.
It could be be like when they were
younger and I was just like, man,
this dude is massive. He's
just Khabib as a bear. Yeah,
he's could be mystic as fuck.
Yo Wells on another level.
Freaking like a he a gargle.
He like built like a little
gargle or something like,
but when he knocked up Chris Weidman
with that flying nail, I was like,
Jesus Christ, he's just,
he has this like slow move and he
sets these traps on you and explodes.
Where do you feel like, like these
veterans, that sport is changing so much.
So now you starting to see all these,
these vets try to figure it out.
Like why am I going to light
heavyweight? Look this,
why am I going to lie to him? Healy man.
So it's like is these guys
like, because obviously this,
this with Dana White's contender series,
all these fresh guys are starting to,
the sport is changing so fast.
It's like now these guys are
starting to become the Tito Ortiz,
chuck Liddell [inaudible] of the,
now it's like this new fresh cause.
Thinking about it, it's like
Jordan said, it's going to all,
it's going to be somebody better
than me one day. Michael Jordan.
It's going to be somebody way
better than Jon Jones one day. Wow.
Think about that. The evolution of the
sport. Well that's what we've seen,
right? When you go back to the
old days, the tank, Abbott days,
and then you see what you see today
means that's unrecognizable and you're
talking about 1993 to 2019 what is it
going to be like in 2030 the field baroni
days? Oh my God. I mean what we're going
to look at in 10, 15 years from now,
it's probably just me.
You're seeing it now with the Tuesday
night contender series and with these guys
coming out of one that you
never even heard of before,
the Johnny Walkers where you
come from exactly that knots.
You can guy that knocked
out Eddie Alvarez,
like who the fuck is he like is a
monster. Never heard of him before. Right?
There's so many guys coming up right
now that no one's heard of that are just
dedicated and driven and focused and
they also have a higher benchmark.
You know, they've seen the mighty mouses,
they seen these guys and
they know that this is,
this is the level they're
trying to achieve.
Instead of, you know, looking back
at the early days, you know, we're,
we're guys just weren't as complete as
they are now. That's great. Do you think,
what is the,
Dana has said plenty of times there
will never be a cross promotion when you
think it is. Will it ever be po?
Would you like to see that
one versus UFC champion?
Like I'm the worst
businessman of all times.
I'm not about protecting any brands. I
don't give a fuck. I would be like, yeah,
come on, let's fight, let's fight. Let's
all make money. I don't care. You know,
I'm not, I'm the wrong guy for
that. Like if I was the, I would,
I would make the UFC lose
money. I get paid people more.
I mean I'm not the right guy for that
job and I think that I would have a lot
more weight classes. First of all,
I wouldn't have a jump between 85 and
two oh five that to me looks crazy.
Like why don't you have 10 pounds
every 10 pounds? One 65 is neat. Yes.
One 65 is Kevin Lee would
be, could be champion easily.
Then (556) 057-0580 five all the way
on up 95 two oh five to 15 to 25 more
fights. Yes. More fights. More champions,
and I think it's the
right way to do it. Also,
I feel like it's weird that we call it
welterweight when it's one 70 and now
glory calls it welterweight at one 72
welterweight and like in the sugar ray
Leonard, Tommy Hearns days, it's
one 47 that's welterweight. Yeah,
because Mayweather was a welterweight
champion at one 40 that's 45 Singh.
That's boxing.
That's the fucking legitimate original
name for that weight class is the boxing
name. They called it welterweight.
They called it middle mate.
They called it cruiserweight.
It was their names.
So what we've done is some weird thing
where we decided why the fuck you want to
call it welterweight? It's like,
you know, I live on Brown street.
They have fuck you brown
streets over here now.
How can we have two brown
streets? That's ridiculous.
That doesn't make any sense. Why
wouldn't they create one 65 they should.
I don't know.
I don't like what would be
one of my relationships with
Dana white is we're very
good friends and she got the guy
to death of loved him forever.
He got me into commentary. If it wasn't
for him, I'd never done it, but I don't.
I don't do what he does. I don't
want that job. I said get it.
I don't agree with him on a lot of shit.
I don't agree with him on the weight
classes for sure. I don't think,
I don't agree with 'em on some
of the rules. I don't know.
There's a lot of shit. I
don't agree with it. You know,
there's a lot of things I don't
agree with in the sport in general.
I'm changing my opinion
though about bare knuckle.
I used to think there would be a, yeah,
you like it now? No, you don't. No,
this is for MMA. I feel like
people would get too cut up. Yeah.
I mean I'm, Hallie barely got hit. You
see his face? Yeah. What did you see?
Krystle evens face. Oh, dad
was brutal. The chrysalis.
Pull up that picture from
Chris Levens a thing today.
Dakota Cochran opened up just a
fucking river on his head. It's crazy.
I just feel like imagine seeing a woman
in her face look like we've already seen
it. I mean we've seen girls in Moy Times
in particular. Look at that Gash Dude.
That is crazy. I mean that,
that looks like you fell off a motorcycle
and hit a tree and these fans just
want more blood. Well it's just the
knuckles cut your face up so easy. Yeah,
and elbows cut your face up as
well and you can definitely look.
We've seen some horrific
gashes inside the UFC,
but I think it's harder to hit someone
with an elbow and cut them up like that.
It's like you're getting
a lot of punches in.
You're not getting a lot of elbows
and not getting as many you can.
Especially with ground and pound.
There's a real good argument
for for bare knuckle.
But when you watch these
bare knuckle fighters ever,
the break breaking their fucking
hands, almost every fight.
Everybody's getting their hands
broken. Him loves it. He's an animal.
Harlem is like crazy, you know,
they call him the goat and it's
this funny trolling with it,
but he's a game opponent. He been
fought. Michael Johnson, toughest head.
That was a tough fight
for Michael. He's tough.
The Russian hammers a good nickname
for that dude. And he's a hammer. Yeah.
Look at Paul. And he said,
I got only hit clean once.
He got hit clean a couple of times.
But the point is he didn't do shit.
And I was, and that was bad. I'm a fan
of Pauling, my NRG as a boxer, you know,
and I commentators, he's very, very,
very good as a commentator and
I think he beat Adrian pruner.
I think when he fought Broner
I think y'all pointed him,
but that's what those big ass gloves.
He doesn't have. Uh, no disrespect.
He doesn't have a good body for the
sport. He's not genetically gifted.
It's just not, it's just like he's,
he's got an awkward body like
athletically in an awkward way.
He's just really smart and really tough.
And he did the very best with what nature
gave him and he became world champion.
Yeah.
He became a legitimate world champion and
he knows so much about boxing but it's
a different world when you know the owner
bare knuckles like this proves that we
have the best combat sport in the world.
After that fight I was
like the fuck that guy.
There's some tie guys because our
fight beat a boxer. Yeah. Yeah.
But they don't, it's just,
you can't say it's the best combat sport
in the world cause you can't let them
elbow kick and punch a knee. It's
like this thing about boxing, right?
The sweet science.
The thing about it is if you only let a
guy box and with boxing gloves you get
to see some shit.
Like when you see Floyd fight where
guys are punching them and they can't
fucking hit him.
He's right in front of them and he's
moving away because his knowledge and
understanding of what you can do with
those two weapons is just off the charts.
He's got it focused like a goddamn
laser beam and you just can't touch him.
He's better than anybody that's ever
been in terms of like his defensive,
like he gets hit less than anybody
who's ever fought and had 50 wins.
There's nobody to get some of that
stuff he have after he beat Canelo.
That's a good question. He
fought Pacquiao after that. Yes.
He fought Pat Cardo. He fought Berto.
He falls at the [inaudible]
fight. They fight.
Tim Bradley. Bradley fell out.
He followed him on Donna right
twice if it was after. No, no.
I think the Madonna fight was before and
that was one of the things that gave a
lot of people that
thought Canelo had a shock
as my,
Donna cracked him in that first round
member or not first round the first fight
rats right before the bill. Yeah,
right before the bell and Womble
them a little bit. He stumble. Yeah.
Both of them were before. After they
were, yeah, so that's what I'm saying.
Floyd has some fights after, so, oh,
that's right. The Guerrero fight.
Canelo record was crazy. Even me. Yeah.
Look, man, Floyd is a motherfucker,
dude. He's a motherfucker.
You might not like the
style or the way he fights,
but the boxers that appreciate how
difficult it is to do what he does.
He's a, he's a, a new benchmark.
He's a new benchmark in terms of how to
get out of that sport with getting the,
the very least amount of damage
and fighting the most masterfully.
And he's really changed
the way Canelo fights.
You see Canelo against Danny
Jacobs. Canals is in a lot
of his shit stuff. Yeah.
I mean, he's like, that's
how you do it, man.
[inaudible] crazy when
people like Floyd shift,
like his version of Canelo is like, no,
that was way bigger than that. Come on.
This whole totally different thing.
I mean, it was a legit middle way.
Now you know what the triple g Canelo
trilogy reminds me of member when a pack
out fault. Um, who was it
that knocked him out? Oh,
my blankets. Yeah. One when Mel,
well Marcus, they fought two,
three times a pack. Y'All won twice. Um,
and mark has flat lined, they flat
line them and I was like, Dang,
what if triple g get his third chance?
And that happens cause there's similar
stories like he won, he won twice.
Everybody said Marquez
beat him twice. Yeah.
And then they finally fought again
and then he beat them. Yeah. And Pat,
y'all still fighting though? Yeah. How
is that pause fighting Keith Thurman?
I know that's a tough fight.
That's danger. You can win
it. Yeah, he can win it.
He can just knock out his last
appointment. Yeah. Yeah. Listen,
PACU is still good. He's still good.
And after he got shoulder surgery,
you know what I mean? He's,
he's as good as ever been. Yeah.
I just hate that he keep using that
excuse that he has showed her as messed up
against when he fought Floyd. Yeah.
It would have been interesting to
see him 100% healthy against Floyd.
But Floyd was smart with him. He's
like, not yet. Not yet. Not yet.
Not yet.
Isn't it weird that people say he waited
till he got old but packout was older
than Floyd Floyd's older than pack
yet. Yeah, he's older than pack. Yeah.
But he did wait until pack.
Y'all got a little worn. Hey,
I'm sure he got knocked up by mark
as like, okay, yeah, let's go.
It looks like now's the time. It still
wasn't close, but it was also, you know,
Floyd is incredibly smart
when it comes to promotion.
He's not going to let anybody get 50
50 with him. It's like, no, no, no.
That's the whole Eddie Hearn shit though.
That's what, and then what can happen?
Well, that shit is crazy. It's,
what did you hear about, um,
about him getting hurt before the
fight? I heard that he had a pen, uh,
anxiety attack. Yeah, I heard
it. I heard he got knocked out.
That's what I heard. Yeah. We're
talking about Anthony. Joshua.
That's what I'm saying. Yeah,
but for the people, isn't it?
We heard that Eddie Hearn is
the promoter of Anthony Joshua.
And what I had heard was that he got flat
line and training or dropped and hurt
bad and training and it was
like leading up to the fight,
like very close to the fight, whether
a week or so out. What did you do?
You went well,
I heard that happened in any went to
Miami to finish the rest of his camp after
that. Really?
So that's what I think his
dad was bitching about.
Like Joshua, I'm not a
hundred percent certain,
but his in the ring when they
was getting into it and you just,
like I told you he wasn't right
for the fight. He wasn't, you know,
they were supposed to, they was
trying to reschedule the fight. Yeah,
they probably should have.
They probably when you get
dropped like that and Tracy high,
like the punches he got hit with,
they don't seem like punches at wick.
He also looked a little out of it, out
of it. It's easy to say that the now.
Yeah, but Andy releases a
bad mother fucker. Dude,
that guy throws combinations, man.
Andy Ruiz is a bad motherfucker.
You know, people just get confused
and they look at that belly.
If you took all that fat away and you
saw what was underneath it and he fought
the same way, but he weighed
two 20 and you'd go, wow,
he's got a receipt on Instagram videos.
I'm training how fast his hands is.
I'm like, fuck confusing. Listen, when I,
when they told me to film him,
I think he might've had 20,000 subscribes
on 20,000 followers and then in one
night he had like a million. I'm like,
golly, like, and he
seemed like a humble guy.
He keep like trying to promote snickers,
snickers like every day snickers
snick he wanted that sponsorship.
Snickers need to give him the sponsors.
He likes snickers. He's a big boy.
He's a big boy. Like what
do you think happens?
You're going to do a rematch. And uh,
yesterday, yesterday, Ruiz Jr said,
uh, I'm a beat him worse cause I'm
gonna be in better shape. He can't box.
And I was like, hmm, whoa. He, he was
an Olympic gold medalist. He can fight,
he can fight, he can fight
him bucks. He goes, I just, I,
it sucks cause I was gonna
cover big baby Miller.
I think he's fucked if he fights
Deontay I think Joshua just can't,
he can't hold up under
that firepower. Nah.
Deontay hits people and it's like he's
got some fucking mortal Kombat super
power in his glove. It's crazy. Yeah,
he got that old slave genetics but
he's got that Tommy Hearns frame too.
It's like a giant Tommy Hearns.
Where's all that leverage? All that.
All that torque he hit so God damn hard.
When you look at a guy that has,
what does he have? Like 40 wins,
39 Kaos it's something like that
41 wins. 40 KLS or something crazy.
The only one he didn't Kao is, as we
talked about before was Tyson fury.
But if you looked at the count,
if you had a real clock and you hit
stop or you hit start when he went down,
instead of relying on the
referee to go one and two,
maybe Tyson would have gotten up.
You would've known that it was eight
when it was eight to go with the reverie
was saying eight it was already
10 you know it was like one, two.
By the time he got to eight
and nine and in Tyson sit up,
10 had long been passed.
So technically. Yeah,
but that was also the case with Buster
Douglas and Mike Tyson, you know? Yeah.
I talked when Mike Tyson
knocked down buster Douglas.
Buster dogs did not get
up by the count of 10 no,
I had a real count of 10
and actual ten second count,
but its obligation is to get up by
the referees count, not by a clock.
This year's a fucking clock. Why don't
they use a god damn clock? Early on,
I used to document a Tyson's trainer,
Stacey McKinley after he got
out of prison and he was,
I used to always bring that up
with holy filled and him like,
but he was down 10 seconds.
He was, I don't mean shit.
They ain't nobody caring about that.
Like they, they don't use that as excuse.
Like he was true because he could have
gotten up at eight or nine if they,
they actually have a real clock. Yeah.
It's not like he was out cold and he
woke up at eight you know, he was,
he was just gathering his thoughts
and trying to get his brain straight.
Imagining if an MMA, if
they had standing eight,
why the fuck doesn't boxing have a clock?
Like would they have a clock
when it counts the ring, right?
The ring time swing around so soon as
somebody fall have a fucking real clock
that shows seven, eight not so you don't
leave it up to the Goddamn in a wreck.
You look in the corner and say, oh,
that's it. And he pick it up from there.
The rest, I mean we shouldn't be the
ref counting. It should be like a voice,
like a digital voice. One, two,
three like so it's a
hundred percent 10 seconds.
That's so crazy because one
guy can have a fast count.
One guy can have a slow count.
That's still one guy could
have an envelope in his back,
his suit coat pocket in a locker room.
Just make it a little bit slower. Yeah,
so you just never know.
I looked this up when we were talking
about this a couple months ago,
supposedly,
that they're the time officials supposed
to start the count immediately and then
the era and ring referee picks
it up once he's got a attention.
That is what happens. The problem is the
referee does not do it to 10 seconds.
He doesn't do it to
actual do an actual clock.
That's what happens when the guy goes
down and says go to a neutral corner and
then he picks it up at three full be
off by two seconds easily like a golf
celebrate men and he like,
he spent four seconds trying
to get them towards corner,
but that's on the guy that's
on the guy. That makes sense.
But you once a guy goes to neutral corner,
the fucking clock should be like
a legitimate second clock. Yeah,
yeah. That's crazy.
Or You flatlined people like water
and then they don't get up. Yeah,
it comes from a gentleman's rule,
so I don't know if it was
supposed to be 10 seconds.
So it's parked in your horse in front of
the fucking ceiling on get outta here.
It's 2019 we got clocks,
bitch. This is ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense in a
shady, but boxing shady as fuck.
One thing I like what glory does
though, they incorporate five judges.
These five jewels. I think the
UFC should do that as well.
I think three judges is ridiculous.
When you see bad decisions,
it's a lot like a, I don't know who
the lady Angela Hill just fought against.
I thought it was a bad decision and
I looked at that. I'm just like,
why don't they have five judges,
five judges who know and have five judges
who know what the fuck they're doing.
But you said it was even like they
named one 70 welterweight. Yeah.
What they want to do. Well, boxing
uses three judges too. It's, it's,
I don't know, more than the better.
It's not like it's expensive to have a
lot of judges because remember that score
, that score card they
gave to the draw to Canelo?
Yes. Tim Bradley. No. Yeah.
Tim Bradley and the one no Mayweather.
Kale. Yes. Yeah. That lady, she,
she'd vanished and then she
did it again, right? Yeah,
she did it again with Tim Bradley
and many pack. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When Tim Bradley beat Manny
Pacquiao, everybody was like, what?
Even Bradley knew he didn't win that
fight. No, he didn't win that fight,
but the Canelo one was ridiculous.
That was crazy that to draw, she was,
that's one of those weird things where
it's like all someone has to do was put a
shit load of money on a majority decision,
so like you know that Floyd's
not going to knock Canelo out.
He doesn't really knock
him, but he's going to win.
I put the money on a majority decision
means one person has to be dirty.
All you need is one person who
is dirty. You can win millions.
Boxing is so dirty. It's so old.
You can be dirty. UFC No, right.
Really the judging, I don't think,
I think the judging is incompetent.
I don't believe it. I've
never had any indication.
No one's ever said to me
they think it's dirty.
I think it's incompetent and competent.
There's a lot of incompetent judges,
but then it's also we got state judges.
It'd be weird with the rest. Sometimes.
I see. I was like, who is this ref? Well,
like we were talking about with
Kamara Rosemont and Damien Maia.
That's a ridiculous thing to separate
those two. That's ridiculous.
Let them play it out. Also,
you've got a constrictor,
you've got a guy who's whole deal is to
get you in a bad position and then he
gets you in a bad position
and he's working his way.
He's trying to work his way. He's
got one hook and he's got your back.
He was Tom left to that. It's time
left. It's time break. Break, break.
Fucking break you break. Are you crazy?
What the fuck are you here for? What
are you here for? You? Just one rock.
'Em sock. 'Em robots. You'd go watch
bare knuckle boxing. Get out of here.
But I just rewatched the Ashker in a rob.
I think they could've stopped it when
he'd slammed on me. He could've, could've,
could've stopped it. Could've stopped
it when he was fucking run in his face.
Oh, could've stopped it. But
that was a lot of time left. Yup.
Could've style was in the locker room
where Robin when he came back could have
stopped it. But I wanna
watch that with herb.
Dean had herb in here and we watched
it and herb changed my mind cause I was
thinking that he wasn't
out cause you know,
it's like they got to run that back and
in Camarillo was saying they got to run
that back. That, that he was out or that
he wasn't out with the arm drop. Yeah.
But then I watched it with her but
he's like, this is not a normal way.
Your arm drops. I'm like,
you're right, your eyes.
So he could've just been out for a second
if he was out for a second and just
woke back up. Yeah. Pop back up. And
the way ask her and said it is when herb
started coming over to him, he knew he
was out. Herb started coming over to him.
He let up on the grip a little bit
and that's why Robbie poppy gang up
consciousness. Yeah. I believe Ben,
I believe Ben and I, the arm that is,
you don't let your arm just drop
like that. I think he was out for it.
So soon as he picked his arm up,
he woke back up cause he was like,
I think thumbs up. Ben Clamped on
his head, van squeezing his head,
the arm drops, herb
comes over, look at him.
He thinks he's going to stop the fight.
He lets up a little bit because
he thinks he's already out.
And then he pops back up to life and
then herb subs to find rob. He's like,
what the fuck? I think that's what it,
that's one of the most
confuses back and forth.
Even during the fight I watched the
you and a dominant now he was, no, no,
he was, oh no, he's not. Yeah,
I believe you're right there.
Well you're also looking
through this cage, right?
It's over there and we're like, what is
happening? He's out. He's out. He's out.
Oh, he's not out. Herb was in a bad
anger. He was in, he was in a bad,
and he's the gold standard
though. Truth, the best.
And he's so calm about how he
handles things. Never emotional.
Always logical. You Know Zoe,
where he breaks things down.
He's the gold standard.
Especially now that John
McCarthy's not an intern anymore.
He's doing a great job
at Bella Torta. Yeah,
I mean look belt belt or he used to be,
that was like a clear difference between
the UFC and belt. None anymore man.
So you know I failed Lovato
and Musashi. You see that man,
I level fucking fight mass
crazy. Especially after
Musashi beat Roy McDonald,
which Rory probably shouldn't have
been fighting him at 185 pounds.
It was a wrong way.
Class massage is way bigger than
him and with saucy is beaten guys.
Real top flight guys at two Oh five
and then you know you got Lima who just
knocked out Michael Van and page
Moodle. No promotion on him.
And I was sitting there like, man,
I wish I could've just got my hands
on and told this guy story. Yeah.
Cause nobody knew him. Liam as
a murderer bro. He's a murderer.
His brother in the UFC,
right? Yep. Yeah, yeah. Diego.
But Douglas is as good as
anybody alive at 170 pounds.
I really believe that ash crazy man.
I like it being called champion and
Scott Coker doing. Yep, I do too.
I wished that they would do the same
thing that one is doing with the weight
cuts. Cut All that way. Cut
Bullshit out. Just stop it.
That's not necessarily Michael.
Shannon cut a lot of weight though.
He a big boy. So when he got hit
heavy that's, I always like when they,
when I see him get hit like that,
I see how much weight these guys
cut cause I'm around it. Yeah.
And I'm like damn. He didn't
really get hit like that.
He got hit on the temple though,
right? He got hit the ball,
hit him on pit bull, hit him on the
temple. It's hard. They both hit hard.
It's one of those crazy games where you
know whoever connects first can put the
other guy out. Especially after
channeling knocked out his brother.
It was a big deal. Yeah.
That was a double champion.
A lot of double champions
now. Honor started it. Yup.
You got Bader heated double champion.
You got pit bull. Yup. You got Saludo.
Yup. Dude. Amanda noon to Yup.
So lot. Yeah. Kind of obviously.
Yeah, Daniel Cormier corny. Yeah.
Crazy. It's crazy now. He
threatened it to be true.
I would say if because they gonna have
to do if who, so Hutto is out for a year.
They going to have to do
an interim at bantamweight.
So who you do Aljamain and Peter Yon.
You could do that. That's a good fight.
Yeah. That's a very good where, where
does Cody Garbrandt fit in that picture?
That's a good question. I think Cody has
to win one. Just get in a fight fight.
He got knocked out twice in a row.
Pedro, Pedro Munoz, and you know,
obviously the TJ Dillashaw one comes
into question now the TJ gets popped for
EPO, but what did he say on
Shale? Sonnen's podcasts took,
he had an explanation, the chicken,
because he's trying to make the way,
he must've been just so drained trying
to make that weight. You really do have,
I like TJ too, man. I do too. Sad.
I was supposed to fill on a week
before he lost it. So who though?
And then he was just like, ah,
let's just do the next camp.
He looked like a goddamn
skeleton going into that fight.
The pitcher when he, all those
pills was on the table. Yeah,
it was like 500 bottles. I was like,
why would you just to maintain his body,
keep it alive or he's just basically
draining all the life out of it to make to
125 pounds. He's owning up to it
though. Yeah. He didn't like that.
You gotta face show. True. Sometimes. He
also had a really fucked up shoulders.
Both shoulders are fucked up and he
wound up getting surgery on one of them,
you know? And he had the video.
He was fat looking and with the mustache
I was like, what the hell is going on?
Did he just go to get kidnapped by
aliens and dropped back off? Well,
when you lose that much weight, your
body wants to hold your body essentially.
You wanted to starvation mode and your
body wants to hold on to every fucking
calorie it can. It slows
your metabolism down.
I just think you're doing
a giant to service for the
rest of your life with your
body when you do that. I
think it's very unhealthy.
Brutal cuts take years off your life.
That's what a lot of fighters say, man.
It's a Shawn Soriano.
There's eight hard knocks.
A three 65. I remember when whose mom
was getting ready for the willy fight.
That's my favorite time to film during
fight week cause that's the true raw
emotions is the weight cut.
Everything else is standard.
They gotta do open workouts, media,
it's barn stuff. But that weight cut,
you see these people, souls
and Guzman in there. Uh,
Ben Ashker and they all in a
pit all cutting weight together.
I'm just thinking like this is crazy.
And you've seen the picture with a cowboy
and Tony Ferguson when they was side
by side cutting weight.
That's when neighbors,
they have respect goes to the all time
high with the fighters cause they all in,
they're trying to feed their families.
Man is showing when money. Dude,
Tony Ferguson scares the fuck out
of me. That guy don't get tired.
He doesn't get tired. Could
be respect him. Fights him,
looks like they got run through a
fucking meal. Break hands, right bricks.
What the hell is he doing? Punching.
And you've got big ass hands,
fire everyday and he has big wide hands.
So many people have been
screaming for me to please do it.
An anatomy of Tony Ferguson.
He's so interesting too.
That's what I'm situations
where it's like,
I got to see the how. I
don't know man. It's weird.
I'm in a weird position because
like for example, I like Connor,
but damn, that relationship you got
with Kobi was horrible. I can't, yeah,
I understand. It just sucks
because the Connor team,
before I ever met Khabib, I was on Roddy.
All these guys on the channel, right?
Yeah. And now I'm team could be, you know,
when you get invited to somebody's
country, be around a family,
eat the food with their brothers, they
sacred. Yeah. Like you gotta respect it.
So I respect it. Tony Ferguson's a
different one. They talk shit. But I,
I would love to get Tony
Ferguson on the channel.
Do you think that compromises
your objectivity or do
you think that's just the
price that you pay to
be that close? I know.
I think this the price you pay sometimes,
but I ho I wish fighters will
understand what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to build. I think they do
and they definitely will now. Yeah.
I'm trying to build a
platform from all fighters.
I don't care if y'all fighting it get
ugly. You throw a Dolly through a bus,
you talk about somebody's family and
all this stuff. I get that, ah man,
I can't touch that.
But when it comes to like somebody
like Tony Ferguson versus cubby,
I want to have the access to go with
Tony and Eddie and film that and talk to
them and get inside the
mindset of who Tony Is.
No one has really promoted Tony Ferguson.
I feel like I could do an amazing job
spending a day or two with Tony Ferguson
and talking about life
and I think you could too,
but I don't know if Tony be interest
into it. Tony is a real rebel.
He's a very unique, he may give you a
little bit, but not everything you want.
Yeah, too. He doesn't want
anybody in close with him.
He's got secrets too in terms of
how he prepares and how he trains.
He had one of my good
friends, uh, document them.
His last fight in Vegas, the one
when he fought Petty's he filmed,
he documented him the whole whole time.
So he had a camera crew with them. Well,
I think after his last fight,
I think people are starting to
understand the cowboy fight,
the disguise something truly
special. Everybody knew.
But if you look at is the last time,
I mean Luke Thomas had something on his
Twitter documenting the last time or how
crazy it is of you look like who was
champion the last time? Tony I now lost,
I mean he's a monster. His last
loss was to Michael Johnson. Yeah.
How long ago was that? Long
time. I think it was 2013.
That's crazy that Michael Johnson
beat him. He beat Dustin poor ea.
Michael Johnson man does support
hotline though. At lightweight. Yup.
Kayla and Edson Barbosa.
Yup. Yup. And his,
his tough losses was to gay t who
he, he could've beat gates. He,
he had him beat. They're
both back and forth.
That was in there could
be fight that I really,
I mean that's debatable that he stung
them, but soon as they tagged them,
tagged them. But it wasn't like a, no
flippy hit him. It's a fight. Yeah,
but it could be mauled him.
It grabbed him and it was,
it just shows how good could be better.
You have to give up. I deserve this.
Yeah, give up. That's when I
was like, who the hell is this?
Don't have to be champion. I didn't
know who could be bus. I was documented.
Michael Johnson for the camp.
I know he's telling him to give up boys
beating the fuck. I know I deserve this.
Right. Like Mike on the bottom and
hit him back by like under. He's like,
I was about when he was beating the
shit out of [inaudible] let's talk now.
Let's talk. Boom. He
just beat. So you know I,
I was backstage when he came back in
the locker room. Yeah. After the Malay.
People have never seen that for this
yet. What was that like? It was crazy.
I remember he was like,
we'll turn the camera off because
it was just too much going on. Yeah.
I've never released it yet because out
of respect of the courts, so I asked him,
I showed us a snippet and budgeted.
I just look there. We
need him to fight again.
We need to get past all that
nonsense. Yeah. Trust me.
I can't wait to show the world one day
how crazy that was in the locker around.
But listen, well, we just did three
hours, man. Whoa. Leave that look.
It's three 10 do the clock. Crazy.
Same time weapon, this place.
This was everything I was hoping it
was going to be, man. I appreciate it.
I appreciate you and I think what you're
doing with your channel is amazing.
Your documentary is amazing
and I appreciate. Thanks man.
I appreciate it very much. You fire
everybody. Woo. Fuck three hours.